thank you
so okay
good morning we're about to start a
hearing on House Bill 332 and if there's
anybody here that would like to testify
on it please fill out a pink card and
turn it in thank you
good morning
this is the finance committee at 10
o'clock we have a scheduled hearing for
house build 332 I think I see two
sponsors here I'll call first uh
representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair
I am Michael Cahill all right A Little
Closer okay good I am uh representative
Michael Cahill from Newmarket I
represent the towns of Newfield and New
Market in Rockingham 10.
and I'm here before you today as I had
been
in other occasions to talk about school
building Aid uh you're many of you are
aware this is a long-standing problem uh
exacerbated by the uh bonding of State
funds due to the recession and the
moratorium and the fact that the
moratorium
halted payments but it didn't halt you
know deteriorating conditions in our
schools
so
um with HB
332 I would like to address
really both sides of the equation I
would like to change the 50 million
dollar maximum spend
to 60 million minimum spent
and and this should be I erred on the
the drafting somehow this would be this
would be
inclusive of the debt payment we still
have to pay down the debt so I'm not
asking pay the debt I mean it would be
great if you did pay down the debt and
do 60 million but let's be realistic
so 60 million minimum now the five of
the five of the extra million would go
to help us
with pending projects so that we
wouldn't lengthen that list right now we
have 17 projects for the current
biennium and Only Money enough for three
so that that's kind of sustains the
problem rather than you know rather than
lowering the problem and then we had the
issue of the the many projects that went
forward during the moratorium those that
couldn't wait you know it was supposed
to be a two-year moratorium and then it
was extended and extended again
and some of you will find that uh
schools in your districts were involved
were you know we're in that group
mine certainly was
and you know taxpayers agree they voted
you know they had to had to get 60 60
you know approval and we did that it was
painful
uh they were still paying for it now
extra money you know on the tax bill and
this was you know the school building a
program was something that worked pretty
well for decades and then it was
abandoned you know we've had ran into
some hard times and we restored restored
it a bit with some emergency and then we
went a little bit further but the uh the
tail is a problem and the limit on the
maximum of 50 million is certainly a
problem and I think we need to do
something with this this is another kind
of infrastructure and uh as a note I've
also reached out to the Gopher committee
because there is some federal money left
and I'd like to see that applied to some
place I think probably the best chance
would be to help us uh shorten that
pending project list a bit
but the retroactive I know that hasn't
uh caught much favor in the past but
those people are you know those people
are educating the children in their
districts in the schools that needed
needed to be renovated or repaired and
it was done we did it and we acted in
good faith and I'd like to see the state
of New Hampshire recognize that and I'm
only asking for half of the grand amount
I'm not asking you to pay the whole cost
like we did
in New Market and in Auburn and and so
many other places around the the state
I'm asking for half of the money
and there's a formula that Amy Clark
recommended which takes into account uh
the property values the income and the
wealth the general ability to pay that's
one approach where you're paying the the
more needy communities first another
would be you know uh first in first out
but I'll leave that to the wisdom of the
finance committee but but I am looking
for a commitment to to fund it and to
fund it year after year so that we can
not have these long lists of people who
are you know left to their own devices
in the effort to provide good education
good facilities to attract young
families to keep to hiring retained
teachers we need to be doing those
things
thank you representative Cahill do you
by chance have anything written that you
could give the clerk I I have a bunch of
copies here and more being worked on and
I did send an email with the again I
thought this was division two
and so I only asked for nine copies and
I realized no that's not nearly enough
all right make sure the clerk gets one
and and we can have other we can have
copies made for the rest of the
committee when you give them to Mr
landrika thank you for your Indulgence
questions from the committee
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative for
taking my question I thought I heard you
say that you want the 60 million dollars
um to be less any debt payments but the
way I read this it's it's the other way
around is that right the bill was that
was an error I I you know I'm not sure
how that got in there I think I think
you might see it on that on some of the
other bills today but uh representative
Heath to your immediate left has
graciously agreed to submit an amendment
uh to undo that if necessary so thank
you thank you
a little bit we can expect an amendment
to be brought to division two yes yes
sir
and I guess representative Heath will
take care of that thank you thank you so
much for the questions from committee
members representative Edwards I'll
defer to anyone in division two but I I
do have three questions just so that I
can learn a little bit
um okay uh I I I think these are
friendly questions representative Cahill
so uh I'm just looking for clarity
I I think I heard you say that
um there are 17 projects on the list of
which we have plans to fund three of
them and then I think I heard you say
that you would like us to be able to
take some of the new money and apply it
to new projects instead of continuing to
work the existing priority list for
that's those 17. did I hear you
correctly no I I think you heard me but
misinterpreted my my intent was that we
would we would not invite I know there
will be more projects coming in years to
come but work on some more of that seven
the other remaining 14 to the extent
that we can with whatever arpa money is
provided
okay so as I as I generally understand
the way we were oh I'm sorry uh
follow-up
so so as I generally understand
um how this works is we have this
priority list of 17 if we have an a new
project or some crisis occurs on one of
the yet to be funded projects then
there's the ability to to move that
project to the front of the line for
exigent reasons are you asking for
anything different than that uh thank
you for the question uh no I'm I'm I
trust those who did the ranking on the
list I'm just adding trying to add money
okay you know to the to the fund uh
through the extra extra 5 million you
know the directive board 60 million so
it's a five of that would direct it
toward lowering reducing that list and
hopefully some multi-million uh from the
arpa go for money would make a big
difference thank you Mr chair second
question
no no yeah it just feels like it uh so
um I I I think you're asking for retro
activity uh and and I know uh with my
constituents in Auburn they'd love some
unanticipated money to to reimburse for
the 13 million dollar bond that we did a
few years ago do we have a history of
retroactively funding projects that
local districts had approved and
accepted the the commitment that they
were getting into do we have any
precedent for for a retroactive School
building Aid uh I'm I have not
researched that I would certainly be
glad to look further I I know that the
on the other Branch the executive
Council
routinely approves uh contracts
revisions retroactively so it's not like
an unfamiliar term in this in the uh in
the building
uh the problem was that you know as as
you know that your school needed work
and the state wasn't funding it uh the
state is in a better position now than
they were and I'd like to see your
constituents in line uh get some of the
reimbursement back roughly half of the
of the amount that would have been given
to them and I think that would be a fair
thing to do okay and then my third and
final question if I might this is just a
coordination question I I know that uh
Senator Lang is proposing a bill I'm
just uh what what he's wanting the
school building Aid to focus on is
helping districts that need to
consolidate and so my question is are
you and Senator Lang uh talking and and
trying to smooth your bills or or do you
see these as in Conflict uh I
I haven't uh I we had some emails back
and forth I hadn't seen his bill uh
they're not really in Conflict there has
been an incentive for districts to uh to
consolidate where possible I believe
there was an extra five percent for
every sending Community which I had kind
of mixed feelings about that
um but there are places that can't
consolidate maybe you don't want your
first grader on an hour bus ride each
way there are places where it's not
practical and so and those for those of
us who are in single school districts we
like it that way and we we've built it
that way and I know it works for us and
I'm sure that's true of a few other
places around the state
uh and we we you know we did look at
sending some of the kids elsewhere and
we had an opportunity to send a few of
them to Oyster River uh but that was
only a few you know so we we've been
around this you know and for us it was
uh best to stay with our K through a
sort of pre-K now uh through 12 right in
New Market
all right thank you for that thank you
Mr chair
further questions from the committee
members representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the questions could you clarify
the language in paragraph B Because when
you described it you said you know 5
million would go to retroactive funding
the way I read the language is at least
half and potentially the Empire increase
could you clarify what the intent of the
language is right uh the the 60 million
is the minimum that we would spend each
each year
so there's flexibility to spend 62 or 70
million if we're really flush but I'm
asking for uh
half of the extra money
because you know basically 10 million
which would be half of that would be
five so again I suppose it wouldn't be
out of the question if we had if we were
swimming in money and we wanted to get
this done to to speed up the payments uh
for the current projects and to the
retroactive such as yours and mine
follow up if I may follow up
I I would appreciate our clarification
because the languages I read it does not
say 5 million it says at least 5 million
and I I want to understand your intent
because obviously we will need to uh
figure out the best way to finalize this
bill and I I it's important for me to
understand what your intent is I I
appreciate the the question
um
let me look back it does say at least
five right at least
well yes I think what we're thinking
here is that of the additional funds at
least five million yes it could be um
if if that is a problem for the
committee it could certainly be you know
limited to 5 million or you could leave
it at at least so that you have
flexibility in budgets going forward
it's going I realize that we have to do
we have to look at the money we have
available in each biennium and allocate
those funds and not more than that
so there's some flexibility here but if
that is an anathema to the committee I
leave you you know up to you to Define
work more clearly if that is your
pleasure thank you
yeah I guess division two will will work
on those details
representative leishman uh thank you Mr
chairman and perhaps representative
Cahill you said this and I missed it how
did you arrive at the 60 million dollars
versus another number like the old 50
million dollars well thank you for the
question I believe 50 million uh as
we've seen is is inadequate because we
do have 17 projects and we can only fund
three
and uh the next by your name I don't
think that would improve the ratio so I
think it needs to have some more money
added there may be I think there are
other bills that ask for substantially
more I'm trying to look at what is
possible
and perhaps passable by asking for
60 million instead of 50.
thank you thank you Mr chairman
further questions from the committee
thank you representative Cahill thank
you very much
I have a pink card from another sponsor
representative Cloutier
thank you Mr chairman members of the
finance committee for the record I am
state representative John Cloutier from
Sullivan County district 6 which
comprises the communities of Claremont
and Croydon and I'm here today as a
co-sponsor and in strong support of
House Bill
332 relatives to school building a
and I appreciate the prime sponsor
asking me to be his co-sponsor because
he and I have had a conversations for
years about the whole school building
Aid issue and I know he's had challenges
in in Mike and his community and in my
community we've had challenges too
and let me relate one of the reasons
that why I'm a co-sponsor and I know one
of my other Claremont colleagues is also
a co-sponsor that we had to renovate our
high school some years back
and basically if Stevens High School
which is the public high school for
Claremont did not get renovated it could
have lost its accreditation uh which can
cause problems for graduates and and
just the whole community so the school
board and the communities try to do
something about it and I remember in
we tried to pass a bond we had to get 60
percent and the bond issue lost by just
one vote
which at least proved a point to me when
people complained hey make sure make
sure next time you get out and vote if
you didn't every vote counts there was
it excuse me it passed by one vote and
then there was a recount and if then it
lost the 60 percent by one vote
and so if we had passed in 2009 we could
have gotten some building Aid as I
understand it so the school board in
trying to win more support because they
didn't prefer to pass comfortably they
went back downscale they tried to reduce
some of the cost and they did that and
then I believe it was in 2011 they came
back to the voters and we passed that
bond issue that time with a comfortable
margin the problem is a few months later
we in the legislature and then Governor
you know basically shut the window on
building it they cut it out of the
budget because we had had to make
massive budget cuts in order to balance
the budget and that's fine we've got to
do our cons meet our constitutional
obligation that no one you know wanted
to raise any Revenue it was just after
the Great Recession
and the problem is the City of Claremont
or the Claremont School just had to bear
that burden of renovating the Stevens
High School totally on its own and
that's why we became the community with
the hot highest property tax rates in
the state for a while we had to go go It
Alone in renovating Stevens High School
and I think this bill is a start it's
part of a conversation I know some
people don't like the retroactive
feature but it's not gonna it's not
asking for everything but it's asking
for a small piece back to help us in
Claremont uh make sure that we have and
it is a beautiful building I remember in
2013 after we did it then Governor
Hassan came and helped us dedicate it I
just wish you could have brought us some
money but you know her hands were tied
but the point and this is not a real
partisan issue because I was here we had
as a democratic legislature and then a
Republican election and a Democratic
governor throughout had to deal with the
Great Recession and the problems on the
state's revenues but I think we need to
now look at this again and communities
like Claremont maybe give them a little
bit of help and granted this bill I
think is a modest bill it's not going to
give them everything it's going to give
them half and it allocates just up to
five million dollars per fiscal year and
I think it's it would be helpful for
communities like whether it's New Market
or Claremont or any other communities
that face have faced these struggles and
funded these projects within the time
period of July 1st 2009 and June 30th
2019 which which Claremont meets as I
described in my testimony and I think
you know it was a 16 million dollar
project and if we could have gotten some
building Aid according to this chart
that I have I believe the state could
have
uh paid for maybe
nine nine million nine point six million
but the point is that would have been
very helpful to Claremont and kept our
tax rate down
and I'm sure some of you here complain
and I hear complaints all the time from
my constituents or on social media about
the high property taxes and we as a city
and a school district are trying to do
our part to keep costs down but we need
some help from the state so I urge you
that this committee and division two to
study this bill thoroughly and to give
House Bill 330 to a positive
recommendation in some form and I would
be happy to work with a prime sponsor
and division two to help do that if
necessary thank you for listening
questions from the committee
I have one yes go ahead we normally had
a
a rate based upon the tax base of the
towns like my town said 30 percent is
all they could expect from the this bill
puts in 50 for everybody
um is that the intent you want to change
the ratings that we have done in the
past
um I'm as I said I would defer more to
the the prime sponsor I just want to get
some help from Claremont if there's some
details that need to be fixed or make it
more acceptable to everybody else on the
committee I understand sometimes some
compromises but I'd be open to that but
I just
uh I think 50 is fine but if you want to
go to some other percentage I'm willing
to consider it well historically there
have been other percentages okay so I
just right now and you make a valid
point but I don't I don't know I'm not
uh I'm willing to consider other you
know some changes but I I understand
your point of view as well Mr chairman
okay I guess division two can bring it
up representative Hull for a question
thank you Mr chair
good morning can you hear me good
morning yes go ahead please represent us
so I I just want to understand the
rationale for retro looking back
retroactively versus going forward right
you you did bring it up
um decisions were made by the town of
Claremont
um if I understand it correctly
Statewide enrollment is dropping across
the the state I'm not sure about
Claremont in particular but why
retroactively looking back to to fund
projects that are already complete
versus prioritizing new projects where
there might be expanding numbers of
students in a school system
up good point representative and I
normally am not a fan of retroactivity
but understanding the circumstances when
we approve that bond in 2007 we had
expected some help from the state and
and I know a few months later we in the
legislature had to cut that and I was
par part of that legislature so even
though I I vote against the budget I
still am responsible because I was there
and I just think we need to make it up a
little bit to my community and Newmark
and other communities who weren't able
to get that State Building Aid during a
very difficult economic time so it's
more a moral case uh and as a result it
downshifted it was another example of
downshifting and we became the the
community had the dubious dissection and
maybe it's no longer true but if having
the highest property tax rate in the
state we still have a high property tax
rate and I hear as I said complaints
about constantly from my constituents
you know I'm making them more okay so
representative
papavichi Miller
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
the questions
just a quick question and if you don't
have the answer on the spot I would
appreciate a follow-up
um what is the you know expected life of
the you know School versus the duration
of the bonds that were taken to pay for
the construction project
and again I know you may not know I I'm
not sure I know it's it's it's a much
more beautiful building than it was and
I went there so uh and it's a one of our
great Assets Now I don't know maybe 50
years at least uh but that's just a
guess uh I think someone else may would
but at least 50 years and I think that
would hopefully last that long because
the previous it really we we it probably
was a had been 50 years before we had
done it you know it was 50 years earlier
we had done in fact 60 years I think the
1960s we did put an addition on that
building I think goes back to the the
1870s and we I remember in addition was
put on the early 60s just before I
started high school but I don't remember
anything
um yeah well I'll you know Majors you
know since until that renovation
occurred uh after the vote was occurred
in 2011. thank you everybody follow-up
follow-up thank you and the duration of
the bonds how long will the bonds last
for the town
I'm assuming at least 20 years 30 years
I don't have the exact details but
normally from my experience in bonding
you go at least 20 years if not 29 30 30
years something like that thank you okay
any further questions from the committee
members
seeing none thank you Mr chairman
and
um we have three bills on on Bill on
school construction Aid so we'll be
hearing from maybe some of the same
people and uh all these bills will be
going to division two
um any any comments from division two
chair
okay
um
thank you
we also have signed in
thank you Mickey uh in favor of HB
332 Barrett M Christina from the New
Hampshire School Board Association
Jerry uh
free through
can't quite make the last letter out 46
uh done us
Donovan Street Concord New Hampshire SAA
and Zach Sheehan 64 in uh North Main
Street NHS ffp all in favor
and that will go in the record
I will end that hearing on House Bill
and
we'll be ready in one minute for
house bill
anybody here to testify on House Bill
541 if you would fill out a pink card
representative Waller is the prime
sponsor and will be ready to hear from
her
incidentally somewhere in my paperwork I
did find this
this very good handout some of you may
also have received it
uh purest Bureau of school facility
Bureau of school safety and facilities
and it's got a lot of the data in here
as well as some of the one
some of the ones in
in that handout we just got
thank you very much
billersky is here
I will now open the hearing on House
Bill 541 FNA and call on his prime
sponsor representative walner
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
finance committee my name is Mary Jane
walner I'm a state representative from
Concord and a member of the finance
committee
so the bill you had before you from that
I have submitted is actually just is
basically an Appropriations bill I mean
it appropriates a hundred million
dollars into building Aid in the year of
24 and 25.
right now as most of you know we've been
appropriating about 50 million
but what happens is over half of that or
close close to over half of that is used
to pay debt service so actual
construction and renovation projects for
our communities is really only 25
million to uh per per year or 50 million
over the bienniums so this just raises
that for the for two years
and um I do believe that there is a
surplus I think this would be a very
very good way for us to help our
communities
with one-time money
it after the this biennium it would
revert back to the 50 million per per
year
it's really a pretty simple it's really
pretty simple it just raises the amount
of building Aid that we share with our
communities and I think all of us are
from communities that either have had to
face construction or renovation or will
in the future but most a lot of our
school buildings in New Hampshire are
needing needing updating or needing to
be completely
renovated and new construction put in
place
so that's my testimony
thank you questions from the committee
representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question which communities or
how would it be determine be determined
which communities would receive these
funds
using the process that the Department of
Education already has in place
this would just allow more communities
to be eligible I think as you heard 17
communities applied and only three
received funding this year this would
just allow this would just allow us to
continue with the process that we have
in place and actually I think the
materials that the Department of
Education has provided us on building
Aid are excellent and I I learned a lot
reading through them and also hearing
hearing the department talk about them
so they have a very a very good process
in place it's just they don't have
enough funds to distribute
further questions from the committee
representative emmerich
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
the appropriation is for 100 million
and but over here we've got to spend at
least 50 million
is that I'm understanding with what this
is uh yes so if you go to the first
um so if you look there right now in law
the way the words read are not to exceed
50 million the new words would be it
would be not less than 50 million
but in this biennium we would
appropriate 100 million in each year
okay thank you
further questions from the committee
representative Heath thank you Mr chair
um thank you
um
representative walner for taking my
question I had to stop myself from
calling you by your first name
um did you in the presentation by the
department and I looked at the materials
I didn't see it is there an amount that
tells us exactly what is owed on the
tail
um I think there's a chart well I I've
been looking at this chart and now you
all have it so this this chart you might
have to
you might have to do some addition
um yourself but this chart which you now
have is really very informative about
how much building Aid Debt Service we
have still to pay off and it's really
limiting the amount of money that we're
allowed and able to send back to our
communities and isn't that the idea
isn't that really what it is about to
try to help our communities
follow up a follow-up um
as part of this
proposal would you consider
um
in your allocations creating amount and
amount of funding that could pay off the
bond that we owe all together so we no
longer would have a tail
well I have heard people talking about
that idea I think it's really an
interesting idea and certainly would
um help us
not have this situation that we have
where we out we're out we are allocating
50 million dollars but that 50 million
dollars only half of it or less gets
back to our communities
I mean I don't think that people
are really aware of that how much this
debt service is costing us so
um I think it's an interesting idea and
certainly I think something division two
well I'm sure
um entertain and talk about
thank you
further questions from the committee
represent hole thank you Mr chair
um the one see thing I don't see on this
chart is what the interest rate is or
the effective interest rate for those
bonds is there a way to find that out
I'm sure the Department of Education
could give you that information I think
there is somebody in the room right now
from the Department I don't off the top
of my head know that thank you thank you
further questions from the committee
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair I I had to step out and so
is is your proposal representative
walner that we pay these bonds off
faster than the decline or or is this
new money to pay off the bonds faster
uh well that that is
that is a suggestion that I have heard
out there that's not what this bill does
okay this bill appropriates
additional funds each year for two years
but would still pay down
the bond rate the bonds
there is a proposal out there I've heard
people talking about it I haven't seen a
bill that people are talking about let's
take this one-time money that we have
there's these one-time funds we have and
pay down pay Down The Debt Service just
pay it off
and then that will allow us to have more
money available for Grants to our
schools follow-up oh I I think you and I
might have been in the same meeting uh
do you recall the conversation I I had
asked the question about if there was
any penalty to repay these bonds before
they were due and I could have sworn I
heard
us being told that we really could not
because the bonding pay these particular
bonds off faster than scheduled I I just
I don't remember what the department
said at that at that meeting but I think
like I said they are in the room we
could ask that question again you know
if it's a different way to look at it
yes ma'am thank you
any further questions from Committee
Member for representative walner
seeing none thank you representative
walner thank you
I also have a card from Kathleen Murphy
Kathleen Murphy is recognized to testify
on House Bill 541.
good morning
welcome to finance
there you go I've got it now I'll start
again thank you for the opportunity this
morning for us to offer our support for
House Bill 541 I'm Kathleen Murphy I'm
the superintendent of schools for the
Concord school district and joining me
this morning is Jack Dunn and Jack is
our business administrator for the
Concord School District
I would like to take a little bit of a
different turn on my presentation this
morning the reason for that I could
probably sit here for hours and talk
about the needs in our school buildings
and the repairs and the updates and the
the need for new construction but I'd
like to ask the you to be thoughtful
about some comments that I have to make
that I think are relevant to the work
that you do every day it's very clear
research is very clear about the
criteria for which businesses and
families move to a community
there are two major items for that and
that's housing in schools so schools are
really important to communities when
businesses establish themselves for
instance in the city of Concord as well
as when we have new families arrive in
our community our schools are important
an example of this happens in Concord we
see at the hospital we see new doctors
new staff coming to the hospital and one
of the things that they always ask us is
can we have a tour of the city can we
see the schools and there's a reason for
that they want to know if the school is
making an investment in their Community
do they feel strongly enough to make the
effort that the state as well as the
community because it's a partnership I
know you all know that that in funding
our school construction and by by
visiting our schools touring our
buildings they are able to see that
commitment and I think that's an
important consideration for you as you
address House Bill 541 which would
increase building Aid
another example that we see in the
district I often get calls from families
and they they're new to the district
they're moving from wherever as you know
we're pretty mobile Society now and in
Concord particularly we're really
fortunate because we have folks from all
over the world uh who join us and they
always ask to visit the schools why do
they do that they want to know where
their children are going to be every day
they want to know what kind of building
it is is it safe does it have the
accommodations does it meet the needs of
our new Learners and so we take
particular time to be to give tours and
to explain the facilities and the
availability of those facilities and by
the way don't forget our facilities
extend beyond the school day we're not a
seven to three operation anymore we are
a building that our buildings in Concord
in particular and other school districts
that I've worked in they're Community
buildings we don't own them they're the
they're the they're the buildings of the
people and and and in thinking about
that uh our our buildings are used for
multiple reasons for girls and boys club
activities the why
um we have uh Girl Scouts and boy scouts
uh and needless to say all the
recreation opportunities uh that the
youngsters have they use our school
buildings
recently
um the department of Ed was trying to
deal with a teacher shortage
um and we're all faced with trying to
attract the best teachers that we can
for our kids every single day
and I I want you to know that facilities
is a factor in that Recruitment and when
we're marketing our schools I want to
make sure that every classroom is
staffed with the best teacher I can find
and one of the things that I use is
touring the facility so when somebody
has an interview they don't just come in
and we ask them a lot of questions and
they leave we give them tours of the
building and that's a significant impact
on people who want to work in our
buildings they want to see what the
facilities are they want to know if the
if if the facility meets a current
accommodations for all of our Learners
and remember our Learners are very
eclectic now we have English language
Learners we have Learners that have
learning challenges
um and and and our typical youngsters as
well as lots of Hands-On learning
project-based learning outdoor education
so people coming in I especially our new
hires are looking for those kinds of
resources and so for me it's really
important to have that as part of our
package
um
one of the things to that it struck me
when I was thinking about what I was
going to say to you today is when we
bring new businesses and we bring new
families into the community that that's
a revenue for everyone that's a revenue
for the state because now all of a
sudden we see increases in real estate
taxes we see increases in simple things
like room and meal because we have more
families more businesses participating
in our community and I think that's a
plus so for school building Aid it isn't
just about building a building and
accommodating in our case we have a need
for our Middle School we have 851
students attending that school and about
a hundred plus staff that are in that
building every day and so we want to
make sure that we have a building that
appeals to folks but in doing so that
the families coming in offer something
to the community as well as the state
through increase cases in revenues
one of the other things that's happened
with buildings this is particularly true
of a lot of communities in our state and
having been in education for quite a
while I've had an opportunity to see
that and
um in Concord for instance when when
they built three new elementary school
buildings they took buildings Offline
that means those buildings were no
longer going to be used as an
educational facility but that didn't end
there in Concord now the businesses
bought that building and now those
businesses are paying taxes and in the
community so that happened with several
of the buildings that conquered took
offline in addition some of the
buildings are used for the community
right now we have the boys and girls
club using a facility Head Start is
using one of our older buildings we have
our Concord Community Center a vibrant
place for families to go to on a daily
basis and in the evening those that
building is used and it was a former
School building so it isn't like we take
these things offline and in many cases
they bring Revenue to the state and I
think that's an important
aspect of what we're asking for today as
we increase building Aid
I'll be sure I promise I think I said
five minutes
you know what happens when you get a
school teacher up in a microphone
and one of the things that I've I've
really experienced over my career is the
trades I I finished a project in Hampton
I think representative from Hampton will
attest to that and it was it was awesome
we brought in the Building Trades the
the plumbers the electricians HVAC all
of the folks most of the people that
were contracted in that project were
from New Hampshire they were New
Hampshire companies
and what better way to in increase
opportunities for our businesses than to
have construction and and and and make
sure that people have jobs uh good
paying jobs and I I think that's an
important aspect
um increasing building a and I'll I'll
try to summarize here but increasing
building Aid to public schools has an
impact as I as I outlined on so many
fronts and I and I I think we've talked
about jobs we've talked about the
opportunities for additional Revenue
we've talked about attracting new
businesses and families uh to our
schools
our Middle School in Concord is in very
poor condition
I have to tell you that we were number
four on the list and as you know only
the top three were given the funding so
we were incredibly disappointed to be
number four but it's kind of puzzling
for me to to realize that only three
School in our entire state were eligible
for building Aid especially given the
years of moratorium
but I have to tell you that it does not
meet the standards of an appropriate
middle school for our 851 plus over a
hundred staff each day who attend and so
I urge you in closing to support 541 and
increase building Aid to our Public
Schools thank you
thank you superintendent do you have
some written testimony you could share
with the clerk I can share this with you
yes
um do you have any may I uh yield to my
good business administrator yes please
spell out your whole name so we can have
it in the record my name is Jack Dunn j
a c k
d u n n
business administrator for the Concord
school district for the last 10 years
um I think we support uh representative
wallner's Bill 541 but I think there are
some creative ways you could utilize
those funds to be able to fund all 17
projects
um I think the the state has gone from
one extreme to the other by allowing
multiple building Aid projects to happen
and paying for 20 to 30 years over it to
now trying to fund 50-year buildings as
uh representative uh papavinci Miller
had mentioned what's the life of a
building that's typically what the
Architects tell us 50 years but funding
a 50-year building over two years so
there may be a way to utilize funding in
this bill to amortize that maybe over
five years and be able to take care of
17 projects and get rid of a large
backlog of projects and satisfy a lot of
your constituents just a suggestion and
I'll be proposing to our school board a
solution to do that if the state can
come forward with some funding
I think if your testimony questions from
the committee representative Sweeney
thank you Mr chairman and thank you both
for being here my question if we were to
appropriate the additional increase as
law outlined in this bill and some of
that were to go to the city of Concord
School District would the school
district commit to lowering School
District property taxes by an equal
amount
of the offset
and there's I'm going to answer it in
two ways
one the Concord School District already
does that by lowering property taxes
because what it does is it equally it
equally impounds dollars from every
taxpayer whether they moved in and moved
out because
we earmark five percent of our general
fund budget for Debt Service so when our
debt service is above five percent we
pull from a stabilization fund when
we're below we add into the
stabilization fund I wish every school
district would do it but trying to
convince taxpayers to vote to do that is
very hard
this will allow us to do that
I can build our school with no tax
impact with this funding
and I could show others out of that way
follow-up
thank you thank you for that would the
school district commit to lowering
property taxes by the equal amount that
the aid would be increased in this bill
we'd have to look at the numbers okay
thank you
for a question thank you Mr chair
um thank you for taking my question have
you passed your bond yet for the school
well you understand that Concord is
autonomous and the board makes that
decision and the board has voted uh
unanimously to move forward with a
building project for the city uh uh to
to look at the middle school great thank
you
further questions from the committee
I have one
then you're next
um when you took these three schools
offline
you said you sold one or sold two we
sold and gave away multiple buildings
first Walker School which was now been
immediate was not on the tax rolls now
on the property tax rolls the old
Rumford school off Thorndike off tax
rolls now on to the tax rolls sold to a
private investor who made it a community
school the old Dame school which is up
off of Canterbury was given to the city
for one dollar even though there are two
separate school districts in the city
and they turned that into a community
center for the city of Concord and the
Eastman School which is up on charmot is
being rented the boys and girls club and
Head Start
when you sell a building yeah what do
you do with that money that money goes
into our stabilization fund to offset
any impact from school building or
projects capital projects so it could be
used to improve another building or to
build another building and we've done it
thank you further questions
representative papovichi Mueller thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking the
questions just have a question in terms
of looking at the long-term picture with
the state school building Aid is it
meant to bring money into Concord from
other communities in the state or just
to help you flatten the fluctuations in
the property a tax rate due to the
impact of the bonds used to pay for
school construction obviously you
already described that you have the
stabilization fund but that may not
catch everything so I'm trying to
understand your intent when looking for
a school aid in those terms it's both
thank you you're welcome
further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you both for your
testimony thank you thank you we have a
few minutes left is there someone here
from the Department of Education that
could answer questions that have arisen
Here Comes Caitlin and she will tell me
her title now
Rector Caitlin Davis good morning that
is correct Caitlin Davis for the
Department of Education
and we do want to just let the committee
know
um I do want to just let the committee
know that the department of education
does plan to do a presentation tomorrow
relative to division two specifically on
a lot of these topics we do have a
handout in front of you that has some of
this information but we will be here
tomorrow Amy Clark who is our engineer
who oversees a school facility program
will be here too to talk about
many of these topics in much more depth
than I am capable of
providing you
a few questions though that I have heard
that I can answer is that how much is
remaining on the existing bonds across
the state for the tail
um so it's 136 million dollars that 136
million dollars right now does include
fiscal year 23 which I believe is about
25 million so whatever 111 million
essentially for 24 and each year
thereafter
we cannot pay off the existing bonds the
Department of Education has had
conversations with the New Hampshire
Bond Bank relative to the existing bonds
but I do want to clarify I know there
was a question about the interest rate
on a v Bond it is a series of bonds that
local municipalities have taken out over
a period of time to pay for building
projects and the Department of Education
under the old building aid program used
to give Community communities a
percentage of the Total Bond over the
course of 20 years we don't do that
anymore the program has changed where we
pay a portion up front and then nothing
over the life of the bond but so all of
those existing bonds and the existing
tail are local community bonds which
might have varying interest rates in
varying different time periods of payoff
so
I'm glad you brought that point up I
think people don't understand the
complications it could be dozens of
separate bonds that are being paid off
that's why the tail is slowly
diminishing we might pay off one or four
bonds one year and have a bunch left the
next year so it's very complicated that
is completely correct glad you brought
that
questions for the committee for the
director
representative Mooney thank you Mr
chairman thank you Miss Davis good to
see you again in terms of Eligibility to
apply for school building Aid I happen
to know that public charter schools are
not invited to apply for such Aid
because I have a bill that will include
them that will be heard this year at
some point are there any other Public
Schools excluded from applying for
school building Aid not that I'm aware
of
all right representative Edwards uh to
follow up on representative Mooney's
question I I've I've been told that
public academies such as Pinkerton uh
are excluded from applying from school
aid and and so if you could just double
check that I'd appreciate that
representative McGuire for a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question it's been 10 years
since I was a member of division two so
I don't remember these answers I'm sure
I knew it at one time can you we've
heard that there are 17 that that
applied and three that have received a
funding
what how does that work is it just first
come first serve does a certain ways
certain ones get to the top of the list
and so on and since you were on division
two
's actually
so even if you could remember it it
would be irrelevant so
um so the program now works is every
other year the Department of Education
accepts applications from school
districts relative to school building
Aid school districts have to submit a
letter of intent to the Department of
Education on January 1st of every year
and a completed application by July 1st
of the of the same year the Department
of Education then uses a set of ranking
rules or sorry a scoring criteria that
is in rules to rank the projects based
on the the information provided in the
application there's also site visits
that are required as part of the process
and there's a team of individuals at the
Department of Education including two
Engineers that have done this work
the Department of Education then takes
its ranked list and presents it to the
school building authority and the school
building authority then takes the
Department's rank list and gives it to
the State Board of Education the State
Board of Education approves the final
list and publishes the list by January
of the following year
the Department of Education then will
present that list as part of its budget
so right now we have that list that was
approved in the month of November by the
State Board of Education they met their
deadlines and we will be presenting that
as part of our project budget to show
you those schools that potentially could
receive funding
so I do want to clarify a point from the
committee when we're talking about three
schools have received funding to date no
schools have received funding the
Department of Education has a list of 17
applications that we've received as of
July 1st completed applications I should
clarify that we have ranked that and we
look at then the list and we say these
are who are who is going to receive
money and I believe that is in your
packet and how much funding that they
are eligible for and how much money the
project is in total then the department
will wait to see how much money is
appropriated in our budget in each B1
and potentially hb2 there was some
funding provided in hb2 last year and we
will go down the ranked list and let
schools know that we have funding that's
available to them the school has then a
time period to pass a bond locally and
if they do pass the bond locally then
they will receive funding if they are
unable to pass a bond we then will fund
the next project down on the list so
right now the department is estimating
that with the amount of money that we
will have available to us
assuming that we first pay the existing
tail of about 25 million dollars and
then any additional Debt Service the
state has on existing bonds that we will
have essentially another 30 or 40
million dollars available to us over the
course of the biennium the then we will
then go and offer to schools so we
believe right now and that's with the
existing law with the cap of 50 million
dollars so then we assume that we will
have enough funding likely if if the
legislature were to fund that full 50
million dollars at least the first three
projects on the list the fourth list on
the list is Concord
um and Concord would receive if we were
to receive if we received they would
receive some funding but we would not
have any funding to rest to provide
funding for their full project amount
meaning the others on the community
would maybe not receive funding around
the list would not receive funding now
of course if the first four on the list
for example don't pass their bonds then
we might fund four through eight or
whatever the order of of them passing
their bonds are
yes thank you so
um
assuming that it goes the way you
described that the first three get
funded and Conquer gets partially funded
um the next year does Concord become
number one or new ones come in and the
Concord would have to reapply and all
the other 13 would would have to reapply
how does that work that is a good
question for Amy Clark tomorrow
okay
I hope there's no further well J.R Hull
we're coming up on 11 o'clock and I
don't want to keep representative lad
waiting because I know he's got 100
bills to go work on representative Hull
for a question sure thank you two quick
questions one
is there a reason and maybe historically
there is that they fund fully the first
the top applicants and don't distribute
it amongst the balance of the applicants
that is the way the program is designed
okay
and then follow up
follow up close to the mic please
follow up um
when this bill was presented it was
talking about 100 million dollars worth
of excess that was available now going
in the bill looks like it is going to
appropriate
um almost two hundred thousand dollars
between the two years separately is that
correct
I am not sure okay
okay any further questions from the
committee seeing none we will close this
hearing on House Bill 541. thank you
director Davis
and we will open the hearing on House
Bill 546 and I see representative Ladd
is here to present and
after closing 541 I will read the list
of people who have signed in in favor
representative John Cloutier senator
um
Whitley from Hopkinton Baron M Christina
from New Hampshire school board
associations Jerry fru from New
Hampshire
SAA Jack Sheehan from nhsf
nhsfp Kathleen Murphy superintendent of
SAU number eight thank you
representative
glad you're recognized to testify
thank you very much representative
Weiler it's a pleasure being here with
Finance
as always happy to have you yeah uh I
have passed out a pack of the materials
uh I hope everybody has one in front of
you because I'm going to just take you
through this very quickly
okay it looks like everybody has a copy
now there are a few extras here
um just to make sure you got the the
same materials I have in front of you
the first page is a page that I put
together the second page is from the
Bureau of school safety and Facilities
from Amy Clark and it shows you the
history of where we've been with school
building Aid including the dates in
which we had the moratorium and
subsequently how many how many building
applications have been approved since
the moratorium
um it's interesting to look on that that
we've had the number of applications
funded you can add them up it comes to
six since we've had this moratorium six
building projects have been approved one
of which was an emergency I'll get in
that a little later the second sheet is
based upon our formula shows you the
percentage that we as a state are
obligated to help if one of these
districts receives
School building Aid it's interesting
note it's anywhere from 30 percent to 60
percent and this is one area in our law
where we really do have fiscal capacity
our fiscal Aid disparity Aid due to the
poverty level in in a community it's
important to keep that in mind
let's see the next sheet down
or you skip a page because it's just a
second half alphabetical order the next
one shows you where we are with Our
obligation on our debt here and you can
see that by the year
2041 we're we're done with it
however we have an obligated debt that
we're paying off as we go through in the
previous last several years including
this year I'll get into specifics but if
we allocate over the biennium of 100
million dollars for the biennium both
years 50 million of that goes off to pay
debt so we're trying to take the
remaining 50 million dollars and use
that for new construction or renovation
projects that have been accepted and
gone through the process and the process
is very extensive process which starts
with the Department organizing and
rating and and putting them in some kind
of a a sequential schedule as far from
highest to the least and then it goes on
the school building authority then the
state board for approval the last sheets
and please excuse my handwriting on on
the side on it what I was looking at is
equalized property valuation rates
etc for each of these communities we
have 17 projects to put in for this
biennium that we're looking at of which
we I heard you talking when I came in
the room that there's a potential we
might be able to fund three of those of
the 17.
so let's go back to the front sheet here
and and look at what I put on there a
little chart there what my bill does
right here is we're trying to put
guarantee that we will have 50 million
dollars for
construction new construction and
renovation on top of what we have to pay
off as our debt and that little chart
there that table kind of shows you what
the debt would be for FYE 27 18.2
million dollars and so we'd have to
allocate a total in a budget of 68.2 if
we're going to have the 50 million
dollars on top
why we need this renovation a new
construction projects back when we
developed the various schedules for I'll
go back to about 2009 89 on the delivery
of an opportunity for an adequate
education we did not include school
facilities as part of the leg of what an
opportunity of edge opportunity for an
adequate education is seeing that we had
another funding formula in place to
provide for building construction
so you won't see building Aid as a part
of our adequacy formula itself but it is
very closely tied to academic
achievement very closely tied to
academic achievement we have renovation
new projects a need for it because of
unsafe conditions compliance with idea
overcrowding and associative influences
on our curriculum and instruction yes we
have some districts are declining in our
demographics we know that our population
when I started out here in the house and
represent why are you way before me here
I was on City Council in Homer Alaska
when you were sitting here doing your
thing here but
when I came in on 2008 and up to this
point in time the population of our
state was around 210 plus thousand kids
Statewide
now we're down to 160 some people 161
164 000. we have lost a significant
number of students however that's not
true to every every situation in this
state there are places where they're
maintaining there's also some school
districts which are growing in
demographics
so that's something we have to look at
in terms of overcrowding and Associated
influences on our instructional spaces
uh and when we talk about that we're
talking about conferencing we're talking
about classroom spaces we're talking
special education we're talking about
library media center Jim uh cafeteria
all that
um I mentioned a bit about this is the
only area in law which we really do
provide fiscal capacity based upon
measurable criteria the percentage of
kids eligible for free and reduced we're
looking at poverty
uh we we also need to have projects
going forward to remedy remediate or
remedy imminent danger and we have some
situations one of those six projects
which we've approved recently was a
result of that was one in my home
community of Haverhill where we had our
school population as they spoke
representative Weiler earlier this
morning in the hall downstairs we had
kids for special education were in an
old house beside the school district and
the top floor was condemned by the fire
marshal as having mold and not meeting
fire code conditions we also had another
building where we had housed part of our
vocational then but it was also part of
our Sciences program we had asbestos in
the ceiling and hanging out we had one
bathroom in this facility which is many
times the size of this one bathroom in
that facility that was only for it was
in the staff member's office
so what we did with that Grant we
brought all this back in and of course
and their representative Hill is the
chair of the of the uh School building
uh
whatever your committee's called right
that but uh he they came up and saw this
we did have issues so now we've tied it
all together through that Grant so we
have education going on one place where
special ed kids don't have to rock
across a parking lot to mainstream and
get involved with other aspects of our
programming and much more in terms of
security we did not have good Security
in that whole complex
um one of the things we look at why we
need it because there are projects that
will contribute to the operational costs
efficiencies we can bring kids from
three buildings into two buildings and
saving labor costs we can save on
operational costs uh costs of fuel Etc
by moving them into one over a period of
time and that's something we need to be
looking at seeing that many of these
older facilities which we have if you go
down to the bottom here just below the
chart you'll see 50 percent of school
buildings in New Hampshire are over 60
years old
they have the old heating systems that
are just could you could uh with tubes
in it you could probably heat the Queen
Mary on it you have ventilation systems
in classrooms that bang and Clank an
Elementary's classroom teachers are
putting the mittens and the hats and the
gloves of wet wet gloves to come in from
the recess yard and they're stinking the
rooms up and we have to keep changing
filters within those old machines it's
not the type of air quality control we
would like to have seeing that our
science and our medical people say this
is not right we need to cure and fix
some of that
six percent of these buildings were
built prior to Nineteen Hundred
now we're talking about well over 123
years old some of these buildings
seven schools are over 69 years old and
not had a major renovation in the last
50 years
196 schools 60 percent of our schools
originally built prior to 50 years ago
backloaded building Aid projects an FY
10 if not y19 there's a backlog and as a
result of this moratorium we had one
other school that we just recently gave
a grant to up in rumney New Hampshire
they could not get a parent who's in a
wheelchair into the building because the
building was up four steps
we couldn't put any of the in the second
floor we couldn't put handicapped
students in the second floor
there is no elevator there's no way up
to it so the space in that building was
very limited
and and and created a lot of
difficulties for that particular
Community since then they have an
excellent principle up there in John
anston fantastic job and we have had a
project paid by us in the state we
contributed to it and it's it's helped
that schools tremendously
how does the education facility uh
impact learning I believe it really is a
part of adequacy if you don't have this
chemistry Labs if you don't have the
sciences that are necessary you're not
going to be able to to compete against
the schools that have all this in place
we need to really think about where
we're going with school building Aid and
the 50 million dollars we've been
providing which includes our debt has
just not been cutting it uh the
difference in achievement scores
in a student that's in a old building
versus one that's new and shiny and has
all the wells and whistles bells and
whistles 17 top points difference that
can be as high as that normally it's a
little less than that but it can be
between five and ten percentile points
but achievement is different
as we go around I know some may question
that but this is this is a fact there's
lots of research behind that
we have new needs in our schools nursing
programs are growing by by Leaps and
Bounds we have some folks that have
nurses hidden away underneath the stairs
we have nurses stations that don't have
bathrooms and we have nurses rooms that
don't have showers in it we have kids
that are now living in vehicles
we need to do something about providing
those Services the adequacy of space is
necessary to do this and and these
districts which have the need for fiscal
capacity it cannot do it they they're
taxed to the hilt already they need to
have the state getting into this with
their 60 percent you notice that the
schools that have improved that
tentatively are on the list the three
schools Rochester
Colebrook Monadnock where the looking
elementary schools
sixty percent sixty percent fifty five
percent these are schools really need
that the next one down is a Concord
which also needs it but they're at a 30
level I believe
when we're looking at Colebrook you're
looking at a school right now that's
shipping their CTE students across the
river to Canaan Vermont that program has
not been improved they're recognizing it
Colebrook had to close the old Academy
building scene that was just not fit for
what we're using now they have their
high school kids in that middle school a
school that's designed for elementary
education
they are on the list to receive funds to
renovate that building and make it
appropriate we have other situations
just like this in this state but Amy
Clark is having to go through carefully
and try to prioritize these rank order
them there's folks on this rank order
and yes the question was asked if
they're on this list right now are they
automatically going to be in the list in
future years no they're not
we might have something come in that has
a higher rank in terms of safety Health
Etc Fire Marshal stuff that has to go on
top so I'll conclude my presentation I'm
sorry to take so much time up but here's
a quote on the bottom of this sheet
the success of our whole system
depends as much on a thorough reform in
the construction and care of
schoolhouses as upon any other single
circumstance whatever
that was presented to this house this
body in 1847 by the commissioner of
common schools
folks things haven't changed
we've done a lot to improve and yes we
have a lot of things happening in our
state where some schools have space to
utilize but we have other situations
that are just old just because we have
space doesn't mean that building is
usable so thank you very much for your
time and I take any questions you may
have
thank you representative Ladd questions
from the committee
representative papovichi Miller thank
you Mr chairman and thank you Mr lad for
taking the question yes just a really
quick question I was looking at the uh
other change in the bill that you are
proposing that the building age shall be
non-lapsing and continually appropriated
it does look to me that removing the
ability to elapse funds uh if they are
not needed in a future budget May
encourage you know may limit the
flexibility of future legislatures and
potentially encourage spending beyond
what is needed could you explain the
intent behind that language we have some
other funds which are non-lapsing funds
as well I also chair the commission for
public school infrastructure that's a
commission that we're looking at I I see
represent Heath she's on that committee
commission and we we have been looking
at Access Communications uh security and
all different dimensions for these
schools in the state in which we've
allocated out over the last several
years
um the first go around it was 28.5
million dollars now we've re and we had
a uh access money or left over money on
that we didn't use that came back from
some of these grants which we had
um uh given to school districts but they
got the cost to come in less so there's
a 1.3 million dollars left over we took
the other two point million dollars
which was allocated for the
infrastructure funds last year
school buses I don't know if you
remember that in hb2 and we combined at
3.3 and now we've used that this year
for security in our schools as well it's
non-lapsing money it goes back into the
in the till for that purpose
um I don't think
personally there won't be a whole lot of
non-lapsing money in this account seeing
it's all going to be used if you're the
last school and there's money left over
it goes the next one on the list they
have to make the decision there where
they're going to take half the money or
they're going to wait and throw the dice
to see if they can get a full funding in
a later year uh so I I'm going to leave
how finances are handled to this group
right here I'm coming forward and as
representative Weiler and I've talked
often I'll do the policy stuff I'll
inform you that we're in a world of hurt
in terms of of school buildings I'm
asking the finance committee here to
address that and recognize that and help
us in this fix
thank you you're welcome
further questions from the committee
representative Edwards
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Mr chairman
um so I as I'm listening to this I've
been thinking about
um how the state funding may be viewed
by the local community in the Auburn
Village School we went ahead and decided
that our renovation was so important we
did it anyways uh anticipating no State
support to speak of and and so it makes
me wonder when you say that there's a
rule of the dice uh on whether they
might take half the money in the hopes
that they could get all of it the next
year isn't there a logical argument for
taking the adequacy formula because you
mentioned that this is kind of part of
adequacy taking that adequacy formula
and putting some amount of money in
building aid for all the schools so that
we're empowering the local communities
so they know what kind of building Aid
support they can anticipate and then
instead of gaming the state budget they
can focus on what they need
you're on course and and what we're
looking at there's another bill which we
have in education which is looking at
from A to Z the whole application
process the timeline for this is awful
right now if we have to have these
applications in by July 1 and then by
January 15th after going through all the
Hoops of the school building authority
the doe the school building authority
the State Board of Education they have
to come out and say Mr District you are
being awarded a grant on January 15th
that gives us less than six months to go
through and scrutinize all these
applications for Amy put everything in a
rank order to get out on site and see
what we've got out there to better
understand and the letter of intent and
going back with the whole process with
your schematic design which is part of
the cost of the school district we'll
have to start at least 18 months earlier
now in your in looking at where the
money for these projects comes from
that's a good question does it come out
of the education trust fund do we do
something set it up like that there's
been discussion of that I know even
within doe
um I think where you are is there there
has to be a source for this it's one
thing we've got to understand this is
not part of adequacy this is not part of
acquis I say it should be but it's not
uh it's it's you know we have
instruction we have curriculum we have
assessment the fourth leg I think is
really do you have a building
if you don't have a building you might
be able to do it online but that's not
eyeballed eyeball instruction and you
don't have the labs the facilities Etc
so
um I think that where the money comes
from is something that Finance needs to
look at I don't and ways and means I
don't have a handle on all that
um you guys do
follow up okay so based on your last
comment I don't think we should
anticipate next year or this year seeing
a a proposed Bill to shift building Aid
into part of the adequacy formula
instead of this method correct but we
agree I think that this method creates a
lot of wasted motion of having
localities come to the state only to be
turned away because there's no room in
our end wouldn't so so wouldn't it so
just to make sure I understand your
testimony you think it might be
preferable to put the school building
Aid as part of an adequacy formula so
that we get the state less involved in
local building decisions
I I
don't know quite how to answer that when
when we were pretty much funding every
project came down the road when I came
in here we had 540 million dollars of
debt that we have obligated ourselves we
are borrowing from our Visa card using
our MasterCard it was that type of a
game
we were so far underneath we went
through this moratorium
um to say now that we're going to lock
some of this inadequacy I think the
source has to be established but we also
have to recognize we have buildings out
there that need help and and and how we
do that where the source comes from I
don't have uh I mean we had a study a
commission looking at funding I didn't
vote in favor of that was the 16-1 vote
I was the opposite side but we were all
together in terms of where we were with
school building Aid
um I I think because when we initially
got there it was separate from adequacy
I think what's wise to stay separate of
adequacy but for us also to recognize
that we do have something in it as a
state the town local has
a commitment they have to have some
ownership in this project too no
ownership there's not going to be what
we want as far as understanding where
those dollars are coming from and care
of the facility's maintenance of the
facilities
there's a lot to be done on this
representative Edwards and um
we've kicked the can down long enough on
this we need some money out there to
help these schools now now I understand
we're not going to be able to change
things for the two years you're talking
about in the budget right now but we
need to get this squared away for the
following biennium
but thank you Mr chair
representative emmerich for a question
thank you Mr chairman
well representative Ladd
will you win here in the testimony by
the business manager from the Concord
school system was here
oh you were I don't think I was here for
that one okay well he made a comment
that said we ought to think about how we
support the communities because he said
our formula seemed that we take a
50-year school and pay our portion in
two years
and so I think what he was referencing
kind of backhandedly was maybe we ought
to look at how we do this instead of
tinkering with it we ought to say here's
a better way to do it where we basically
partner with the community and fund over
20 years our portion as as they are
paying theirs over 20 years or something
like that I'm not I'm not trying to get
a conclusion but is it better to have a
strategic discussion on this rather than
all the tinkering around trying to fix
what doesn't seem to be working this
discussion needs to be strategic in
nature when we initially had the old
formula
we did not provide the school district
the community the 80 percent up front
and upon completion the 20 of our
portion the state aid the 30 to 60
percent that saved on a lot of interest
uh on the principle that the district
was you know having to take out when we
funded it over a period of 20 years
so that that is one small component that
we have to be looking at in in a
strategic plan where how are we going to
do this and and we need to have
involvement from both the local and the
the the state however I want to remind
all again that there are some districts
that just don't have the capacity
the fiscal capacity deal when you look
at their economic status and situation
to provide what we are putting out that
you will be teaching this this and this
and and yet it's almost it comes down to
it's almost like an unfunded mandate
we're we're telling to do this but we're
not going to provide you the facility to
do it in
thank you you're welcome representative
emmerich for a question
he just asked a question to me
I I have a question
do you know on the criteria for how they
put people in the queue to get the money
do they use the fact that they may be
growing in population do they use the
fact that they may not have spent any
money on maintenance let the building
deteriorate and then come to us crying
you need to give me a new building
everybody should be maintaining that is
criteria and for example we had some
buildings for example there was a
building even in my town
where the middle school was built in the
early 1990s
they had a two stories here and they
were venting out of the art room up the
Kiln up the side of the wall into the
attic and about one point 15 years later
the roof is gone
and you know why all that moisture was
up there and it was eating out there was
no maintenance being done we now since
have if any kind of a building project
the clerk of wore of the works of that
particular project by state mandate now
is has to be a qualified engineer and
bonded or like an engineer an architect
it can't be your head custodian who is
good at the job but not a engineer and
is guessing what's behind that wall
whether it's asbestos behind the wall or
just air
so there there's a lot to this
um
the we do have a requirement that if
they bail out of this building from
using state aid in 20 years they've got
to pay it back to us that's in state law
uh there's a number of things which we
have upgraded to our statutory language
uh since we initially made these changes
and we made these changes working with
the state of Maine they had a pro
program my old athletic director back in
Maine was the commissioner of Education
Duke Albanese and was there when they
put in the building aid program there we
echoed a lot of that so we improved it
but we're not we're not where we need to
be with building 8 at this time
anything further from the committee
represent whole
thank you Mr chairman I'm looking at the
notes that you turned in right going
down by facilities the list of
applications in particular I'm looking
at
four which is conquered in five which is
Litchfield both of which are building
new middle schools
Concord is building a new middle school
for approximately 900 people
litchfield's building a school for
approximately 400 based on the current
enrollment
the disparity between 176 million and 32
million is huge is there any explanation
how we allow for such disparity between
the amount spent per student and
building Aid
you can see on the right hand side there
I I put some numbers down there for you
uh I did this back a while myself for
example if you're looking at concrete
you see 25.12 that's their Equis
assessed value based on the assessed
properties the 22.72 is their equalized
valuation per pupil uh our our equalized
valuation excuse me and and so you see
those differences
um
you have go ahead if you follow I guess
my question is not per student
necessarily but the cost for the
structure is the difference is huge we
have a student a school proposed by
Litchfield that's going to house 400
students based on their current
enrollment and they're asking for a 32
million dollar project and we have a
student sorry Concord is asking for a
school roughly twice that size and
they're asking for 176 million dollar
project and that just both for middle
school and that just that seems a five
to one ratio seems out of whack for yeah
represent whole I remember you on our
education committee years ago
um the that I think that's a question
that's best asked for Amy Clark
unfortunately is not here this week and
she could be here answering that
particular question right now and I
think that if you have a work session on
this one in division two it might be I'd
grab Amy and bring her in
she is an engineer and she's been
working on this and she's been to all
these schools
unfortunately we didn't pass the Bill
last year where we had 3.3 million
dollars and we were going to go around
and visit all the schools in this state
with engineers and architect and an
education policy so when we had our
report we knew what we were dealing with
out there in the schools right now
what's what we're basing a lot of what
we have to do it's based upon what the
district's providing us we have not gone
and done the evaluation use the same
criteria for every school so there's a
lot we have to do in terms of cleaning
up our our whole policy on this so I I
look to you to help us do that
thank you for your testimony any further
from the committee members
thank you thank you very much
representative Weiler and committee
and we'll next call on representative
McGuire to testify
you didn't you didn't include my
position
a member of the finance committee no no
that's not share of division no no my
position on these bills
um thank you very much Mr chairman the
members of the committee for the record
my name is Dan McGuire and I represent
Epsom I'm opposed to these bills and I
wanted to talk in the public hearing
because everyone we've heard so far is
in favor
of school building Aid and I think
school building Aid is a poor public
policy for reasons somewhat that
representative Edwards was was touching
on in his comments but but in general
any kind of policy that moves public
funds from one group of taxpayers to
another
hasn't really accomplished anything
right for the for the taxpayers maybe
maybe the handful of school districts
that are getting funds are a little bit
happier but the other taxpayers where
the funds are coming from are a little
bit unhappier to maybe to the same
extent
the problem is that school building Aid
um encourages higher taxes not lower all
right so as as we all remember from
Governor Thompson low taxes are the
result of low spending the problem is
school building Aid encourages higher
spending why because on the district
that's getting aided we're we're saying
to them if you get Aid you can have a 30
million dollar school but it'll only
cost you 20 million dollars
so the people voting for that school
think to themselves well is it worth it
to me to get a 30 million dollar school
when I only cost me 20. as opposed to
um is it if I want a 30 million dollar
school and it cost me 30 million dollars
the making that that decision
um correctly right the the but but when
you say to someone I'll give you a
discount on that school the the general
result is going to be more school
building than would naturally occur
right so we're encouraging higher
spending here on schools than what
otherwise occur
and higher spending it results in higher
taxes right so so there's must be a
better way to help
property taxpayers and help school
districts and so on then this then this
way which which gives us higher spending
and I would say the right way to help
those districts is what this committee
did two years ago when they reduced the
Statewide property tax by a hundred
million dollars
right because because we had extra money
from taxpayers in general and we wanted
to have lower property taxes so we
lowered property taxes very
straightforwardly but in doing so we
didn't encourage higher spending we did
we didn't throw off the economics of of
how government works right so so this in
general is not a good policy and it's
not something we should be putting more
money into
thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative McGuire any
questions
Edwards uh thank you Mr chair uh thank
you for taking my question I know you've
been looking at this for a very long
time I I guess I'm just looking for
first principles as a first principle
should the state be supporting building
Aid or should the communities be
accumulating the building Aid in their
own resources is there a role for the
state in Revenue sharing
yeah thank you for the question
so I would say in general a bad
um bad public policy is what is
something we do all the time and that is
transfer money from one level of
government to another where the
receiving entity is making all the
decisions right so similarly
um I mean this is why the federal
government is in such trouble right they
pay us a half the amount of money we we
spend on on Medicaid
um and and so we make the decisions do
we have Medicaid or not based on the
fact that it only costs us 50 of what we
get to spend well the net result for the
taxpayers is we're spending a lot of
money uh more than we would do otherwise
if Medicaid was entirely our own program
so so in general I think that levels of
government should tax and spend on their
own and not and not transfer money in
this way now
um you know in some sense we're ordered
by the court Etc to to transfer money
and I would agree with
um with representative Ladd that an
expense of schools is is the is the
school itself right and so and so if
we're if we're doing adequacy the
there's no reason why some fraction of
that like rent could be part of that
that equation
um but but in general I don't
if you if you make as a condition to
receiving the check that you spend right
if you spend this I send you the check
then that encourages more spending if
you say I send you the check based on
some other condition whether you spend
or not right then you'll spend
adequately
follow up okay so what I think I heard
you say is that yes probably the state
has some responsibility to assist the
local communities with school building
Aid or rent as you put it but that the
magic is in how we do it so that we
reduce the game playing that's taking
place in the in the false incentives
that may occur as a result but in
general yes the state does have a
responsibility all right let me let me
try to be more specific so
if you buy the argument that
um
we're all in this together and somehow
wealthier communities and wealthier
individuals should help out poorer ones
therefore the state has to have a role
right
if that's what you're asking right so so
the state that's where the state role
comes from it's it's it's shifting money
from from Able able taxpayers to to you
know disabled ones or whatever but
um
but I don't think it should be a big
role and I don't think that
um again it should be based on uh if I
spend more I get more right like that it
should be you exist therefore you get
something
thank you representative McGuire any
further questions representative
leishman thanks Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question so where is the proof
If we spend more we get more
oh thank you for the all right so
um I'll give you an example of the town
next to mine
um they decided to build a 30 million
dollar school and they were told you
only have to pay 20 right so so and they
decided to do it
the the point is what if they were told
you wanna if you want this 30 million
dollar school you have to pay 30. their
decision would be different maybe maybe
it would maybe it wouldn't right but but
their decision would be based on their
own true economics right I mean if if
you're offered
a car for for you know two-thirds of the
normal price you're more likely to buy
it you won't necessarily buy it right
but you're more likely to
thank you
any further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you representative
McGuire thank you
we have a final pink sheet from
representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee
uh I Rise really because of the previous
speaker and I I want to tell you that
we've done that
we've done that we told the communities
uh we're not going to pay we won't even
accept the applications and yes some of
them did it because they had to
like they were going to lose their
accreditation they had fire and safety
or they really just saw that they needed
to do it
and the the share that the building age
share runs a bit you know basically from
30 percent up to as high as 60 percent
in some cases where the economic need
justifies it so we're not really
incentivizing people to overdo it and it
was a very it's very much a struggle
even when we had building Aid in New
Market I believe we ran it uh different
approaches by like three or four times
and each of them failed because it's not
like people in New Hampshire are trying
to spend money uh we we know it's
differently in our communities we're
we're very uh property tax sensitive so
to say that you know if you in your the
building a program is an incentive to
spend more money it's not true
it's just false we're trying to do
provide an adequate education and an
adequate facility and we need the state
to act as the partner that it did for
decades
thank you
any questions for representative Cahill
being none thank you for your testimony
anyone else here who wishes to testify
on school building Aid
seeing none
we will
read the list of supporters for House
Bill 546 representative John Cloutier
Barrett M Christina from New Hampshire
school boards Association representative
Greg Hill from New Hampshire school
building authority Zach Sheehan from New
Hampshire school funding fairness and
Jerry fru I can read the name that time
from New Hampshire school administrators
thank you all for your input we will now
go into recess returning at one o'clock
to have another bill another set of
Bills starting with House Bill 207 at
one o'clock thank you
foreign
have a hearing on House Bill 207
relative to school district
um at the right bill here
unanticipated funds
and let's see if we have the
any of the sponsors here representative
Platt is recognized
thank you Mr chair and thank you all for
hearing uh my testimony I introduced
this bill at the request of sau19 Scott
grossed the business administrator is
behind me and he'll get into the detail
as will Laura Taylor Who's the assistant
business administrator I did get asked
by them to introduce this bill the
general concept is uh we to cut costs in
in time because twenty thousand dollars
the SC the school board has to set up a
separate meeting to to accept
unanticipated revenues as opposed as
opposed to doing it in the school board
itself which is public but it's just the
cost and time of setting that up and so
if you raise the threshold from five
thousand or Twenty Thousand it will cut
the number of times they do that they'll
provide all of the detail behind that
but that's the general concept
and I've got to go back to my own
committee so a question or two would be
fine but I've got to go back I'm Clark
there so they're missing me
thank you representative plant any
questions from the committee
pretty straightforward Bill thank you
for your testimony
and we will next hear from Scott gross
and Laura Taylor
welcome to finance
there we go thank you Mr chairman my
voice usually carries pretty well so uh
and uh rest of the committee uh again I
agree with you I think this is more of a
housekeeping type bill it hasn't been
um I guess amended in about 17 or 18
years and basically
um we found ourselves over the last
couple of years holding a lot of these
public hearings to accept uh donations
of funds over uh over five thousand
dollars uh and Laura Taylor who is the
assistant business administrator said
Scott you know you got to do something
about about this so I dragged her here
today as well
um generally speaking the ads uh to put
it into a newspaper about a hundred and
fifty dollars on average sometimes a
little less sometimes a little bit more
but it adds just yet another layer of
administrative effort that's needed and
the cost so um Laura can talk to the
cost in a minute uh another issue that
has come up like and it's the weather so
I'm holding a public hearing uh tomorrow
we're supposed to to accept a donation
from a PTA in excess of five thousand
dollars so we're holding the public
hearing well due to the weather tomorrow
night we've now canceled that public
that that meeting and the public hearing
so now we have to have it on Thursday I
can't do it because I have to have seven
days notice in order to accept those
funds so now I have to schedule it for
probably another two or three another
meeting out so it's those types of
things
um again it just needs a little bit of
of updating on on those on those funds
Laura can speak to uh what we spend
typically in a given year in each of our
school districts
thank you for your testimony questions
from the committee
seeing none
I'll ask him you have a white sorry
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so
um is this twenty thousand dollars per
incident per item yes it would be uh per
item and the other thing I I should also
mention is that um the level of
transparency which I think most most of
us pride ourselves in New Hampshire is
our level of governmental transparency
this still goes on our school board
agendas or in the case of a municipality
a select board or a Town Council this
would still go on their agenda so the
public is still duly warned
um we put the agendas everyone puts
these agendas on the website they're
given in advance so there is no lack of
transparency it's not like a school
district or municipality would be doing
anything you know nefarious or anything
it's just a matter of making a little
bit easier to do these jobs and to
streamline it follow up
thank you
um how many did you have in the past
year and what was the total amount yeah
Laura is going to speak to that
in FY 22 Goffstown School District spent
um eighteen hundred and thirty five
dollars on advertisements for public
hearings
um we had I would say two or three
public hearings that were under the
twenty thousand dollar threshold I don't
believe that any members of the public
came to those public hearings and all
donations were voted in and accepted by
our school boards
any follow-up
further questions representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
the questions
um
it has been our practice I was on the
school board in Windham in the past and
we didn't have a separate meeting for
the public hearing we just had it you
know a special it we dedicated a part of
the school board meeting so those who
are not additional costs but do you find
the notice requirements which are indeed
separate you know such a significant
burden
so I'm glad that you brought that up um
I would say the almost all the time we
are holding that public hearing right
before our Traditional School board
meeting
um the the notice requirements have to
be exact so if you mess up in that
notice requirement someone could
question it so if your date is off or if
your time was off you have to then do it
again
um so it's not just about putting it in
the newspaper you have to proofread the
legal notice say from the union leader
if there is a typo or something is wrong
you could be called into question so
it's all those layers so I think you
know from my perspective you're just
adding more administrative you know
burden and again someone had set the
five thousand dollar threshold way back
um 18 years ago and I just think it's
one of these bills that occasionally a
bill needs some housekeeping and you
need to refresh it based upon current
dollars I think this is one of those
bills thank you
representative hacken Phillips
Mr chair
much for taking my question but in the
line of the same
thought train
uh five thousand dollars was the limit
17 years ago just curious are there any
mathematicians that have punched you
know the numbers in terms of what would
that be according you know to inflation
numbers today and is that twenty
thousand dollar new threshold something
that correlates with that inflation
change or is this a you know
substantially larger threshold
um
you know today's money that would
suddenly perhaps create a greater need
for public notification and
participation one that would maybe not
have been triggered at the smaller five
thousand dollar range
I will say that I I did not uh go back
18 years ago and and do the compound
interest uh equation I I was simply
looking at it from the perspective of
you know what would be more or less a an
amount that would you know offer that
level of a higher type threshold
um
that number in my opinion is probably 20
or 25
000 but that's just my my opinion
um in looking at just the last year or
two with inflation
being over eight percent uh I I just
think we are seeing so many more of
these where local ptas booster clubs you
name it want to donate and it just it
just needs to keep up with uh the times
what are the questions representative
Heath thank you Mr chair it's good to
see you both
um in terms of expending those dollars
you also need to raise the the your
spending Authority so how would that
work
um in in Goffstown and New Boston they
have accepted this statute so the
statute
um was
um voted on by the communities of
Goffstown and New Boston and and I would
say
a very high percentage of communities in
the state of New Hampshire have have
been accepted the statute which allows
them to accept and expend these types of
funds but the requirement is if you read
the statute that you have to hold that
public hearing as part of that process
so not all school districts and
communities have accepted it but the
vast majority of them have so in that
particular case it then increases our
spending Authority all right right thank
you
any further questions from the committee
Mr you wanted to add something I do
thank you as a follow-up to
representative hacken Phillips I just
wanted to mention that twenty thousand
dollar threshold that we are proposing
I believe
um as the main person that handles our
financial audits for Goffstown New
Boston and the SAU 19. We Believe twenty
thousand dollars has a level of
materiality for all school districts in
the state
um twenty thousand dollars for
Manchester school district is a drop in
the bucket but for a smaller District at
Hill Berlin it's a more material amount
and so we feel like holding a public
hearing for that amount better
represents all districts in the state
all sizes
representative Mooney for a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you very
much for taking the question just
curious if this has made its way and
been circulated to other school
districts and if you've received any
feedback regarding it
I cannot speak to other school districts
uh both uh Miss Taylor and myself are
part of the uh a group called nazbo
which is the New Hampshire Association
of school business officials we meet on
a monthly basis and my peers
um all are in support of this it's it's
something that is just needed because of
this the outdated nature of the of the
dollar amount and I think Miss Taylor's
point is a really good one in the sense
that this is a compromise between larger
communities like Manchester Nashua
Portsmouth who have you know much much
larger budgets than than much smaller
communities so this seems to be a happy
medium in our opinion not obviously you
you are the ultimate Authority on on how
this law might progress or the change so
we would defer to that but that's the
rationale behind the twenty thousand
anything further from the committee
members
seeing none thank you for your testimony
is there anyone else that wishes to
testify on this bill
seeing none I'll read the blue sheet
also signing in in favor of House Bill
207 Scott gross from sau19
Fred Platt who we heard from Jerry frew
New Hampshire school administrators
Association and Bartlett Christina from
the New Hampshire school boards
Association
is there anyone else that has anything
else to add on House Bill 207
I will close that hearing the bill will
be going
to
the division two for further discussion
and they will come back to this
committee with a recommendation so any
of you that want to look in on it you
can look it up on division two May hold
a hearing on that
we got a couple minutes here before we
get to the next bill which will be
129. so if anybody has any pink cards to
testify on House Bill 129 please turn
them in oh three of them wow
it being 115 I will open the hearing on
House Bill 129 and call upon the sponsor
member of this committee representative
Jess Edwards to test defy
thank you Mr chair for the record I'm
representative Jess Edwards representing
Rockingham District 31 I'm based in uh
in Auburn New Hampshire I'm introducing
this bill today because it's a an issue
I've tracked for a couple of terms now
and
uh recently has been a few months but it
feels recent I had an opportunity to
talk to the Auburn Village School
principal who's here to testify
and she asked me to submit this bill so
so here I am
what is the history on this bill this
bill has been debated in I think two
terms
both times it was passed from a policy
perspective
I tried in both cases to to just let
people know that we had a 28a issue
so I'm I'm here today to really just
point out what we already know what our
constitutional obligation is under 28a
28a says if the state mandates it the
state shall pay for it
the way the original bill
two terms ago was written it was written
as though to flout the Constitution it
was a very short Bill basically two
sentences
first sentence was essentially there
shall be a mandate on schools and in the
second sentence a very clear statement
that the state shall not pay for it that
got negotiated to where the school
districts were encouraged to go seek
charitable donations and the like but
what remained was the state's refusal to
sign up to meet its 28a obligation
so
um so that's what this is about you may
hear testimony
about period poverty and how serious an
issue this is
um and that's not that's not what I'm
here to talk about and I hope we don't
get distracted by that because that's
that's been the policy decision that's
uh that's already been made I just want
to walk you through what this bill does
to the existing statute so if you'll
flip
to the first main page it's all the text
of the legislation is just on that one
page
on line seven it simply flips the and
answers the question who pays
because we've said the school districts
have to pay but we're mandating it that
is the direct violation of 28a so so
that gets flipped then line 11 you'll
see that there's a a bit of a formula
there it says that the schools are
eligible for fifteen dollars from the
Department of Education for every girl
that's uh 12 or older girl or woman
now this is not a biology issue this
isn't you know should start at 11 and a
half or 13 or you know do we need actual
you know evidence this is this is really
a simple funding formula which ought to
be good enough to keep it lightweight
and simple so so it's uh so it says
fifteen dollars per school year for a
person attaining the age of 12 or older
oh
um line 15.
um this is this is kind of new and this
tweaks the policy a little bit this this
is an effort to uh reduce uh vandalism
and petty theft and I think you might
hear testimony from the Auburn Village
School on on what the impact uh and and
cost is associated with that and and
this is just basically allowing them to
make reasonable efforts to to reduce
vandalism and theft
line 17 if there's going to be a request
for reimbursement there needs to be a
new form so it directs that a new form
be created line 19 line 19 is something
that you know I I think if the committee
balked at the at the at the ball price
maybe this is where it might be because
this is essentially retroactively going
back and making the schools whole for
the time period in which we had failed
to meet our constitutional obligation
and that allowing for a back pay it's on
a much limited basis instead of the
fifteen dollars per female it it I think
it becomes five dollars
so even with that though the difference
between the first year and the
subsequent years is
853k so it's a pretty substantial amount
that we saddled the districts in without
meeting our prior obligation so so that
would be the May Cole clause
and then line 24 is an effective date it
basically just says that this would go
in an effect if signed and it would go
into effect for the next school year and
with that I'm happy to answer questions
thank you representative any questions
from the committee representative
McGuire
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
yeah it's that second part that that
troubles me that the past is the past
and it's hard to fix it you know and are
we are we opening a can of worms here
for trying to write all the wrongs of
all past legislators
legislatures
rather than just doing the right thing
for ourselves and going forward
but you know I think that's an excellent
question and one I've kind of thought a
little bit about and I I could see
wanting to drive a wedge to to to to
make the past the past but I also felt
it incumbent upon me to communicate to
the committee uh what it has cost the
schools for are not doing our duty under
our the Constitution and that cost is
853k that
um if we don't pay them then that's what
we're asking them to eat there there's a
small precedent on this that I'd share
um you know we we spent a lot of time we
created that hundred million dollar
settlement fund for the sununu center
abuse and that's 100 million dollars
it's going back into the 60s so so we do
have some precedent that we understand
Our obligation to the Past
um uh even while we're trying to build
this new new center that uh that
prevents that sort of use in the future
so I I I'm guessing this would go to
division two and I'm sure that committee
could have that conversation and make a
determination
follow-up yeah I'm not sure those two
examples are comparable that the that
somehow that what happened at the
susanunu center is the fault of the
legislature
back then
you know it's it's the fault of the
people who did those abuses in my
opinion sure but the state's paying for
it is kind of my point is that we are
setting up some money to pay for the
sins of the past and and uh I think we
did something similar and there's a term
of art for this but it was the um the
money that we appropriated so that the
people who had uh received poor
financial advice from the state could go
and get some small percentage of the
money that they were out because of the
lack of good information so so
so now we're standing your very good
point I I just want to say that there's
another side of the coin thank you
further questions from the committee
representative Stringham
yes thank you and thank you
representative Edwards for taking my
question
um the uh first ques do you think the
schools would get sufficient funds to be
worth the administrative paperwork I
mean we have the smallest SAU smallest
SAU in the state would probably be
getting less than eight hundred dollars
and the second related question is how
did you come up with fifteen dollars per
school year so we we were already
supplying menstrual products all along
so it wasn't wasn't any new funding for
our particular School okay so I think
you I think you actually have three
points in there
um so to the first point
um this chart this asks the doe to adopt
rules and set up a funding request form
I don't I don't know that they have to
make that a complicated form it I mean
based on the math it's what school is it
what was the student population what's
the math I mean it could be a very
simple form that even I could fill out
so so there's that
um and then I'm sorry what were the
other two parts
oh
actually uh I was a weasel and I went to
the Auburn Village School principal and
said give me a number that would
compensate you for your costs so she's
going to come up and you could you can
ask her about that but I basically uh
was a clerk on that uh that funding
issue and then you did have a third
point that wasn't as obvious in there
that I'm I'm just missing
uh it's just that many schools were
already supplying these uh and
presumably under your adequacy formula
yeah so so that is not in the formula I
think that's a fine point because yes in
fact schools were predominantly already
taken care of this what what what
happens though is that we triggered uh
28 a being considered when we made it a
mandate
you know and so so to the extent that we
set up a system in which they uh
incurred
additional costs because they were able
to manage waste and manage theft and the
like and then all of a sudden the
perception at least is that the rules
were kind of mandatory and easy and wide
open it opened the door for more Supply
to be consumed than they had been so so
I I don't know I don't know how you
split that you know maybe in testimony
if it sounds like it ought to be seven
dollars per student instead of 15 but
but I'm just saying I want us to
recognize that there is this wedge where
we violated 28a when we imposed an
additional mandate causing them
additional costs we we are at least
obligated to meet the additional costs
in my view
thank you
further questions from committee members
represent representative Murray thank
you Mr chair along similar lines I guess
given your primary concern here seems to
be the unconstitutionality of the
current situation if this does not pass
do you see it impacting what's going on
now will that will the current policy
and the current
um form of doing this maintain
okay so practically probably not because
in uh let's say people who are trained
and experienced in the art do see this
as being an
unconstitutional
intrusion on based on 28a it would still
be incumbent upon a school district to
Sue and the cost of a lawsuit probably
is not worth the amount that they would
save and so so we've kind of found this
little back Pond or back pool of things
that we're doing wrong that we should
get right but nobody wants to do the
right thing to fix it in the first place
so so I'm I'm proposing that we just fix
it
follow up
thank you Mr chair
um
in that vein
is there can you speak to the
responsibility of the costs if there
were vandalism or what schools would
have to do
um if you're saying that it's
unconstitutional to for the schools to
provide this on their own as opposed to
the state providing it then you also
have in here the provisions around
vandalism do you see the state picking
that up or does the school district pick
that up
so I I need to come back because I've
been inarticulate if if your takeaway is
that I'm I'm I'm saying it's
unconstitutional to provide them
I it's unconstitutional for the state to
mandate them and force the school to pay
for it without our reimbursement that
that's my main point yes I get that but
now I'm asking about
um if a school decides to do something
for vandalism apropos protecting these
products uh where does that lead you in
your discussion around the
constitutionality of paying for that I
think that secondary and not tied to the
constitutionality issue if we allow them
to implement common sense safeguards to
prevent vandalism and theft then I I
just think that's good public policy I
don't think any of us are pro vandalism
or theft so
um so so I don't I don't see that as
part of the Constitutional issue I just
that that's more of the good government
part of this from my point of view in
local control they know what they're
doing
further questions from the committee
representative leishman thanks Mr
chairman and thanks uh chairman Edwards
for taking my question are you aware of
any school districts not providing these
products at the moment
I think all the school districts for the
last two terms have been mandated by law
to comply with this requirement I so I'm
going to just change your question a
little bit because I think it's a more
interesting question to to ask prior to
our passing the law were there any
schools that we're not helping kids get
the medical supplies that they needed
and although there were a number of
anecdotal horror stories during the
testimony and I was I was I don't
remember if I was on a relevant
committee or if I was just interested in
the topic but
um but what what you heard were these
sort of generic arguments that you know
bad things are happening because girls
are too intimidated to go to the school
nurse or it's not appropriate or it's
too inconvenient but I I don't recall
any specific examples of here's School X
and town y that is not providing this
Supply to our students
thank you thanks Mr chairman
further committee questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
what
yeah I gave you two cards sir one is
principal Collins and one is uh the
school board president Mr villanue
I apologize for my handwriting
so so he doesn't want us to do cursive
at his school
thank you I appreciate you listening to
my point of view
I'm speaking to you operationally and
I'm just giving you my experience we
installed we have a K-8 school so we
have Littles and Biggs they share
bathrooms we installed dispensers we
purchased and installed special
dispensers that did not require money
and we filled them with tampons and pads
since we've done that and I believe it
was last July that the bill came into
play
we have had septic issues we have had
pads stuck to ceilings pads stuck to
walls and it is really not the fact that
we've like you said representative of
Stringham we've always provided these
products to our students we provided it
through them through guidance counselors
through female teachers through our
nurse through myself as principal so we
were there for our students personally
on a more personal basis now we have
students going into the bathrooms
stuffing the toilets and it's it's
costly and and I think my point with
representative Edwards was I went from
something that worked really really well
to something that I see a lot of waste
and it's just really purely operational
and waste is my perspective of bringing
this to to you today
thank you for your testimony any
questions from committee members
representative Mooney
thank you Mr chairman thank you for your
testimony and I'm sorry that that
happened to you and your school
um you helped to craft the language of
this bill I assume or you helped to
draft it to some degree my question is
this there's no opt out of this
so what are your thoughts on that sound
like you had a system that was working
and now
um this further says that it's just
going to be done in a different way
your thoughts
red light good afternoon everyone my
name is Alan villanov I'm the school
board chair last 17 years
um that's really a policy question
um we were here more to speak about the
cost that this is uh driven up for us on
our budget
um I don't I don't believe there is as
you point out any language about opting
out if that was something that you
wanted to change I think that's a
completely different bill
um and I don't think would have we might
be interested in such a thing because we
we weren't a district that was
interested in the the first uh iteration
of this anyway as Dr Collins points out
it wasn't an issue for us before now the
legislature has put something on us that
is actually an issue so it's not just
the waste product but we we're having
trouble as perhaps many other districts
are in in employment of uh clean Crews
and staff and janitors so every anytime
any of this stuff goes wrong in the
bathroom that's time that we have to
take away from our cleaning crew and
again our custodial staff to go and deal
with this we're already down two
janitors
um so it's it's very costly we we had
the money to put in for the machines
that weren't wasn't reimbursed which is
fine and you know I I understand the
unders the
regressiveness of part of the bill to
pay for the old things we'd be happy to
move forward in Auburn with with just
paying for it Forward I mean it is I
know in in representative strangle's
district perhaps it's you know 800 or
something but that's still that's just
the cost of a product it's not the cost
of somebody going to fill the machine to
maintain that machine again the cleanup
and all these other things it's it's
thousands of dollars in these districts
or at least in our district to say
nothing of what happens in the much
larger districts where we are just a
wonderful little kid Aid school you
should stop by sometime
um so we're just trying to to do right
by our taxpayers as well I don't know if
that answers your question but
representative Hewitt for did you want
to add further if I may add I I feel as
though
um a student alone in a bathroom dealing
with some of the things that they're
dealing with is is not a great situation
given the mental health situation of a
lot of our students today and that
connection that that just that one
incident might connect them to someone
in our school that will be their trusted
adult forevermore because they know that
that person helped them with that so I
feel as though I think Jess said it is
like have faith that we are there for
our students and that we will do our job
representative Hewitt for a question
is there is there anything in the
current law that requires you to have
machines and to do this in the in the
bathroom
that is the current law
very good man mandated by a previous
legislature
thank you and unfunded
further questions from the committee
thank you for your testimony
next have a card from representative
Woodcock on this bill
thank you Mr chairman my name is Steve
Woodcock I represent Conway New
Hampshire uh and I just like to speak a
minute about the bill uh not about the
intent of the bill representative
Edwards has talked about that how this
bill came into play
I'm not sure as to respond to
representative Hewitt's question I'm not
sure it requires that it has a
mechanical distribution piece in the law
but beyond that my concern here today is
that the bill was initiated uh because
of an attendance issue
if you recall those of you in the United
States should be four uh because we're
talking about three or four days per
month of students who did not attend
particularly from low income areas times
10 months that's 30 days of school time
those students weren't there uh and that
still was existing uh if you recall at
that point I testified in the floor as
an actual example of the teacher and
having that circumstance and it was not
just a student it was widespread
my my concern with the mechanism that's
before you today is not is not the the
uh method uh my concern is that this may
negate the law when you go to the
section in terms of line 15 16 and 17.
and that was the that was the opt-out or
the general inference from years ago
well we can we can go to the school and
error so we can go to the phys ed
teacher or a female nurse or someone and
it did cause a stigma it did cause long
lines and I I feel uh unfortunate for
the Village Elementary School but it may
be because it's an elementary school and
there's a but it may not be but nothing
requires that
um so that was my concern that the the
intent of the law is doing well uh
sitting in the education committee I
have the opportunity to speak with
principals administrators often and
vandalism is rare uh what was what was
happening initially was a lot of the
product was going because people didn't
expect it to be there and then it wasn't
when it wasn't was there next month and
next week the next day that that stopped
uh some folks just have just regular
straw baskets there it's not intended as
a fifteen dollars and the other part is
the cost here it's not intended for
fifteen dollars per per student
um
for the cost of this because we both
know that's not these aren't high
quality high qual top products these
aren't the tampix Galore these are
random generic pieces
um so it's not a big demand item by many
of the women most that can afford to
have their own menstrual products at
home these are the folks that can't
afford it that was the whole point of
this and and just to update on the cost
to concern me so just for your own
iteration today's Walmart prices
36 Tampax 5.98 36 tampons 970. uh pads
from equate 60 for 8.97 and I guess the
always must be a higher brand 36 for 10
47. having not used any of those
products I cannot verify the quality I'm
just telling you what today's market was
um so I think the 15 dollars per student
is way over way overpriced if you're
going to reimburse anyone and it's not
it's not for everyone it's not it's not
the intent so my concern frankly is is
um
just the loss of the law that when you
go to 15 we'll get to well the guidance
counselor has it the teacher has it go
see someone else and we know what
happened there it doesn't happen as you
get older it's just like we we're all
aware of the kids and for the most part
who are in high school who have free
reduced lunch or don't go because they
can't put it because they they can't do
that and this is the bulk of the kids we
have here so I'm asking you to uh think
about as you discuss this law and exec
on this law those that input I'll be
happy to take questions I thank you for
your time
thank you representative for questions
for representative woodcock
thank you for your testimony thank you
again
I have a card from
uh Jeff Monroe
welcome to finance
thank you Mr chairman and
um
all of the committee I appreciate being
in front of my name is Jeff Monroe I'm
CEO of uh representing a brand of new
innovation called egal pads on a roll
uh when you pass this bill many years
ago I've been in the janitorial business
for 42 years calling on all your schools
so I have a vast background of of the
Jansen and what it is
um I wanted to make some points on a new
technology that's out there that will
reduce costs and still give your
constituents uh the product they need
it's based on a rolling could be on it
on a toilet paper holder not a machine
that costs three hundred dollars so I
wanted to make a few points that we have
economical Solutions today that I'd like
you to be considered on you don't have
to buy an expensive machine with the pro
of pill fridge maybe there's not a
receptacle there and maybe it's a pin of
of us educating the facilities manager
so that would be part of our job the
product is being
tested right now at UNH and city of
Cambridge today I'll just give you an
idea had a budget of 15 but the Sanitary
products really come down to to about
two to three dollars out of that budget
and the last point is we need to be we
need to have equality uh you know
there's no one carrying toilet paper
into the uh stall
um it's a woman's right to have that
equality for uh what what she does in
the in this in the uh cost of this is
not what you think
so
um that's my statements thank you Mr
chairman appreciate the information
questions from the committee
representative Mueller thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question I thought I heard you say that
this may reduce Bill footing I
completely understand what it reduces
cost because it's much you know more
economically you know feasible than a
dispenser but I have no idea how putting
this on a roll would actually reduce
pillfering did I misunderstand or could
you elaborate they will you know there
will be there will be some pilferring
but uh what I've found in putting out
the biggest towel system in the United
States
um there will be in initially but the
role goes on and it also has a dispenser
too which will be dispensed one at a
time
so
economically there will be some in the
beginning but state of Utah has mandated
it totally and 19 other states just so
you know
thank you
further questions from the committee
members
yes could you leave that information as
part of our file yes I have the whole
package for the committee and as many uh
pieces of literature for the entire
um board here okay because we'll be
looking at this tomorrow pardon me we'll
be looking at this tomorrow thank you
suggestions
thank you very much to Mr chairman thank
you for your testimony is there anyone
else that wishes to testify
we we have on the blue sheet
Barrett Christina from New Hampshire
school boards Association in favor Steve
Woodcock to Representative Steve
Woodcock as opposed
Alan villanue from Auburn is a pro and
and so is Lori Collins we've heard from
all those people except uh Mr Christina
thank you
we'll now close the hearing on House
Bill 129. then we will open the hearing
on House Bill 468
call on one of the
sponsors representative Hill
foreign
thank you Mr chairman uh for the record
I am representative Greg Hill
um serving the town of Northfield
the snowy town of Northfield
um I think I have in front of you a
fairly easy Bill to uh to handle it's
self-explanatory it's simply looking uh
for an amount of money a hundred
thousand dollars to uh
to begin the process of recodification
of our education statutes
this has been something that's been
talked about since I've been here in
but to my knowledge nothing has been
attempted in along those lines
I believe this is a nonpartisan idea
I will tell you that what happened just
in the last year
pointed out the need for it for me and
maybe this will help some of the the
newer members of your Committee
in my town we had two mathematics
teachers both eighth grade
um both of them taking continuing
education to get a master's
both of them borrowed money to do that
from two different lenders
the lenders after the program completed
and they and they submitted their
paperwork
one lender reimbursed seventeen thousand
and the other reimbursed eight thousand
and the only difference was
the company
determined one company determined that
the eighth grade teacher was a primary
school or Elementary School teacher and
and pointed out the rsas that they use
for to calculate that and the other
program considered the eighth grade to
be a secondary school
teacher and pointed to the rsas that
showed that
so this is this is
illustrative of of the problem that we
have that in some cases our our rsas are
conflicting and some they're duplicative
in some cases they're missing
um so this is a situation where I think
instead of just layering Solution on
solution it may be a good time to start
looking at
recodification entirely
um I will point out two pieces of the
bill that uh or two notes I guess I
would like you to take note of or or be
aware of one is um Roman three
where it says the commissioner or
designee shall have exclusive
supervisory authority over the attorney
apparently the commissioner is not
thrilled about that piece of language
and so there may be a an amendment
coming or forthcoming to division two uh
probably tomorrow I'm guessing you may
want to ask the doe that is
representative that is here the second
is uh the OLS director stopped me in the
hallway just before 1 30 to mention that
this is an idea that OLS is reviewing as
well and they think that there may be
um
Merit to perhaps do looking at this
model for all of uh our statutes so this
this will be an ongoing situation that
you can uh you can be sure will be
coming your way
um with that I'm happy to answer any
questions if there are any
um but I would like to get some honest
footwork ahead here to to see if we can
get something going for a recodification
thank you for your testimony questions
from the committee representative
cabrills
yes thank you Mr chair and thank you uh
representative for taking the question
given the hundred thousand dollars that
would be allocated and given whatever
the attorney's fees may be what
percentage of the education statutes you
think you'd be able they would be able
to cover with a hundred thousand dollars
um my hope is all of them
if if I thought it was going to cover
half I would have made it two hundred
thousand
okay thank you thank you for your
question
you do point out to quite a full book
any other questions representative
McGuire thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative
at one time the legislature had a
special Committee just for recodific
recodifying laws do you think this is a
might be a better task for a legislative
committee or possibly a summer uh for
for the education committee
um thank you for your question I um
I have no idea
um
the honest answer
I really just want something to get done
um it's clear that something needs to be
done and we can talk about uh additional
committees we had a committee on
committees for instance uh
representative evil will attest and that
took us two terms before we could get
that accomplished so
um this was my best shot at trying to
make something happen so I appreciate
your question
representative Petrie for a question
thank you Mr chairman uh if you remember
right uh 11 12 we looked at this very
carefully on the education committee we
figured it'd take six years
to do this properly to go through the
education law which is quite a big task
it would overlap several terms
remember that
uh thank you for your question uh the
representatives memory is much better
than I
further questions from the committee
representative hack and Phillips
numeral two
legislation as it's proposed the report
and findings
for any recommendations would be
basically given to the commissioner of
the Department of Education solely I'm
wondering what the thought process is
through this section my question is if
we're expending public dollars shouldn't
there be some public reporting as well
uh thank you for your question
um
it would be my
understanding that uh that the attorney
shall report uh the findings and
recommendations to the commissioner but
i s I would suggest
um just as with the committee on
committees
um the process was a representative
would then submit legislation with those
recommendations and it would come to
another house committee and then through
the through the Senate just the same way
um probably could spell that all out but
that would be my guess is how how the
process would take place because the the
commissioner doesn't have the ability to
change our statutes it would it would
have to come through and probably
through legislative Administration the
best committee we have
further questions from committee
saying none thank you for your testimony
thank you Mr chair
next we'll call upon Scott gross
thank you Mr chairman my name is Scott
Rose I'm a business administrator for
the SAU 19 and which represents
Goffstown in New Boston I am speaking in
favor strong favor of this bill
most recently I sent a letter to the
Department of Education seeking funding
and it was for a 50 54 year old RSA I'm
going to give it to you it is 198 colon
19 and it deals with area school aid so
when we talk about recodification we
talk about looking over some of the
statutes that are out there I'm going to
indulge me almost it'll take me 30
seconds to read it as an incentive to
receiving and sending districts which
undertake the obligations of an area
school the State Board shall from funds
appropriated by the general court to
carry out the provisions of this chapter
pay annually to each receiving District
sums in accordance with the following
schedule for each pupil from the sending
District in average daily membership in
the preceding school year in an
elementary school forty five dollars in
a in a junior high school or equivalent
sixty dollars in an area high school 75
dollars
the chapter is school money not the
section I sent a letter to the
Department of Education requesting over
thirty seven thousand dollars in the
last two years
to which I was told that the funds were
not appropriated by the legislature but
funds were appropriated by the
legislature for school money so I
disagree with the Department of
education's attorney and their
interpretation my board is going to
decide whether or not they're going to
litigate
I'd hate to do that because laws if this
law needs to be off the books if that
incentive is no longer needed then
strike the law but the law is on the
books and it uses strong language it
uses the word shall the State Board
shall so now my board has to determine
are they going to file a lawsuit against
the state board and ultimately the
legislature for a law that is not being
currently funded or paid
so this is just one example and I
actually have an excellent relationship
with the Department of Ed I like them
but it's a good example of why you need
to go through these statutes
periodically because there is a lot of
outdated statutes that are out there so
um thank you very much and there are any
questions I guess I'm here so
thank you for pointing that out
questions from the committee members
Yeah question representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman thank you for uh
taking my question so it's possible on
things like this that house bill 2 might
suspend section
198.19 for the biennium or something
like that do you know if that's done or
I I don't know and that's something that
um some certainly would have to be
investigated by our school attorney as
to what may or may not apply but in in
terms of
the day-to-day operations of what folks
like myself do or perhaps uh you know
other superintendents Etc we're looking
at these statutes and we're trying to
follow them to you know you you've
created them you've enacted them we want
to follow them we want to follow the law
so when I read the law I don't
necessarily know about how spill two and
all the other things that might
supersede it so in Candor I so for me if
it was cleaned up it would be easier to
say hey this and that this this never
applied in the first place
anything further
perhaps you've sent some ideas to this
lawyer
all right
no questions then next we'll call on
Caitlin Davis director Caitlin Davis
and another lawyer
sorry
good afternoon for the record Caitlyn
Davis from the Department of Education I
don't frequently bring props with me
when I testify but this is the
Department of Education law book
um we sometimes see old versions used as
door stops around this building
specifically but as you can see it's
quite large
um and there's a lot of information very
very useful information so useful in
fact that there's a bill being heard
right now in House Education to make
sure the Department of Education is
providing copies of the law book paper
copies to all of the members on the
committee
now I've been doing this since 2010
working with you all and the number of
times that we go through and we read
this bill or this law book and we find
areas that conflict each other drive us
absolutely crazy and I don't have a law
degree so then I go walk down to Diana's
office and say Diana I found this law
that says this and another law over here
that conflicts with it what am I
supposed to do do I get to pick and
choose when it's convenient for me
she typically says no unfortunately and
then I ask another lawyer what their
opinion is see if I can get a better one
um but it's just there's laws that have
been on the books for over a hundred
years at the Department of Education and
through years and years of rewriting
better more or more consistent or just
different laws there have been a lot of
old things that have been with men left
in other areas or not touched or just
have become become outdated over the
years and it really is not helpful for
the department and for school districts
when they're trying to understand the
work that they're required to do I can
think of a simple example from this
morning when we're talking about
building aid for example so
representative Mooney started talking to
the Department of Education about
providing funding building Aid funding
to Charter Schools a few years ago well
she came in and she sat with Amy Clark
and Amy Clark had said to me I don't
know why we aren't we don't just give
building Aid to Charter Schools the
building a law discusses charter schools
throughout it and what even wrote down
what right down to what rates a charter
school should receive
and then in the charter school law it
says Charter Schools can't receive
building AIDS
so right then and there it's just a
great example of a conflict there's
another a lot of examples you know these
laws some of them there might be a law
from 1960 that's a great law still
really applicable but it's unclear maybe
if it's applicable to a charter school
because in 1960 when that law was
written Charter Schools were not did not
exist here in New Hampshire so the
number of times and examples of things
like that that are just present
challenges on behalf of the department
on behalf of schools could just really
use some external partner to kind of
look at this say you know what are we
what is the intent what are we supposed
to be doing maybe moving sections around
and really just helping everybody
be better at implementing the
requirements of the legislature and the
laws that you've chosen to write for an
education
thank you
so you didn't mark on here for either of
you whether you're in favor of this bill
or whether this is an impossible task or
um so very infrequently do we say we're
in favor but I will go ahead and say
that we are in favor of the bill
representative for a question
thank you Mr chairman thanks for my
question so you guys have a lot of
expertise I'm guessing there's others in
the department with a lot of expertise
in these kinds of issues
given your knowledge of that how long do
you think it would take to actually go
through that book and figure it out so I
do think it is going to be a very
challenging task
um so with the department will we assume
the process would be is for the
Department of Education to if this bill
is to pass and give us an appropriation
release an RFP to get vendors to
potentially apply that hopefully do this
work and kind of give give us some ideas
of whether we think this is something
that could be reasonably accomplished
with the amount of money that's being
proposed or not and if it comes down to
well we can only do certain sections
then you know we'll take that and we'll
start going through that process
there are a ton of education laws this
is also a ton of Education rules that
also will need to be reviewed so it will
likely take quite a bit of time which is
part of why we would like to have an
external partner do this work rather
than just put it on our existing
attorneys that work at the Department of
Education there's no feasible way that
Diana and our other attorneys and our
partners at the Attorney General's
office could accomplish this work
without dedicating a full time to this
work on top of all the additional work
that they have
uh thank you it's pretty much a
follow-up to representative verf's
question
um given given that you've had people
working with that book for a while it uh
It just strikes me that you know the 80
20 rule may be able to come in effect
here so if there's about 20 percent of
the portions of the statute that are
creating 80 percent of the problems is
there a kind of a way to identify the
priorities for repair instead of saying
this whole I I think you kind of implied
it in your last answer but but can that
be done before legislation has passed to
tell us what the priorities are so the
problem with that is it's a really
inclusive project of all of the all of
the laws because I would say for example
the building law has been Rewritten Fair
like recently and we said all right that
makes sense so you maybe don't need to
focus on that but then this Charter
School issue has come to light and they
if you we directed somebody to look at
say just the building a law the school
money law or the charter school law
you're probably not going to get a
product that we really need at the
department we are as individuals when
we're doing our job are constantly
trying to adjust the existing law I can
give you a couple good examples so last
year a bill passed to rewrite RSA 198 38
through 42 which is the law around the
payment of the adequate education
funding formula that funding formula law
we had an LBA audit I believe it was in
2013 or 14 we had proposed some
legislation at that time to fix it
representative Sally fellows when she
worked at the Department of Education
had initially drafted that legislation
we tried several times to get that
legislation passed and it wasn't until
last summer where we finally were able
to get that legislation passed to fix
just that small section I have another
proposal that will be heard in the
Senate shortly about fixing the account
the accountability assessment law us so
this is something that we are doing
through our work on a regular basis at
the Department of Education but we are
really looking for a comprehensive look
at all of all education laws
and I will just simply add to that for
the record Diana Fenton um an attorney
with the Department of Ed this is as
Caitlyn said this is really an issue
that needs to be addressed in in
totality the department continually
brings forward and identifies issues
that need to be addressed but that
really is a piecemeal approach and this
is a wonderful opportunity for someone
to look at this holistically and then
give guidance to the respective
committees in terms of how we can better
address the issues that are raised
really on a day-to-day basis as we work
with this book um
as we do our jobs on a daily daily basis
follow-up
it's it seems to me that you have a
practical hurdle to cross and that is
for whoever is ultimately the the
project manager or the the lead subject
matter expert they already need to know
the law pretty well and then that gets
to be a fairly finite group of people I
mean as you think imagine who might
actually get this external contract to
do this work
is there is there an organization or a
person that's already prepared to be
efficient or or there's a bunch of the
money just going to go to learning what
the statute currently says
I feel that you know most lawyers could
could pick up this project and undertake
it it's reading through the statutes
it's looking at it holistically it's
figuring out where there are conflicts
it's figuring out where there are
programs that are no longer necessary or
needed one of the programs that we
identified as RSA 193 colon 31 and it's
from 1985 it's uh it's education of
missing children and that's a task that
has now been taken on by DHHS as part of
their human trafficking role and so this
is an area that while it is on the books
and this has been mentioned in previous
testimony
this is not a program that is actively
being engaged with another agency has
taken it on and so I I feel confident
that there are many lawyers who would be
capable even without necessarily an
educational background of reviewing
these laws and and doing the work that
we need them to do and identifying some
of these areas of concern
thank you
thank you for the question
for the questions representative
emmerich
thank you Mr chairman uh it it would
seem to me in my past lives I've been
involved in manuals where we kept a rata
you know the oops we didn't catch that
one uh do you have such a
you know spreadless uh Excel or anything
that says oops this doesn't jive with
that I mean it would seem it would start
to settle in to uh representative
Edwards point that they're probably
going to be
fewer areas than than we think and it
would seem like a waste of time to read
the whole thing for these seven areas
that are a disaster for example so I
appreciate that you think it's fewer
areas I think once we start this product
process it's going to be much more areas
than we had ever really anticipated
so um it's funny because Diana and I
were sitting yesterday in her office and
talking about coming here to testify on
behalf of this bill and we were both
just kind of like throwing areas like
well what about this what about that we
don't have a formal document the
Department of Education has been
maintaining but I can tell you from
sitting down with me and my staff and
the administrators that know these laws
and rules and work with them on a daily
basis that we can come up with a pretty
comprehensive list quickly that will
maybe scare put some potential people
from doing the work but
thank you
representative papavichi Miller and then
representative Marty
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the questions we've already heard
the opinion of the Prime sponsor on the
timeline and the budget of this If This
Were a question asked of you without
considering an existing law and we would
ask you how much time and how much money
would be needed to perform a project
like this what would be your rough
estimate of both the timeline and the
budget
um I mean honestly from the Department's
perspective we haven't done a lot of
research on how how much a project like
this will cost we will like we do with
all of our projects releasing RFP see
what those proposals say and those will
come with timelines we have actually
kind of spitballed some ideas internally
saying that you know is this the kind of
some is there companies that exist that
do this work already on behalf of
different laws and states and whatnot
but we are really just in the foundation
of starting to look at getting this work
done so we don't have a great answer for
that Mr Quick follow-up follow-up you
mentioned potentially putting on an RFP
to get a reasonable quote what would be
the timeline and cost for that is that
something that could be done in time for
us to still consider the bill and any
adjustments needed to it
um
so I I don't think that we would get the
quality of bids back or um on an RFP if
there weren't a log requiring the
department to do that
um there's no there's very little cost
associated with putting out an RFP it's
Department of Education staff and time
that that associate with RFP but we
typically wouldn't start that until
there's at least some formal requirement
on behalf of the department thank you
representative Murray for a question
thank you Mr chair uh two things
um when you with great difficulty try to
clean up some of these areas that have
you know issues that you you're aware of
what can you do to make sure that you
haven't created an additional conflict
with some law that's back in 1950 or
whatever and the second question is can
you assure us that there it seems to me
we can't be the only ones facing this
issue and can you assure us or give some
information around agencies that do this
for their living that this is their
professional job
so we don't have the second part of your
question we don't have that data right
now um because we are just in the very
beginning of starting this process
um I hope there are companies out there
that do this and this is something that
very easily just fits into existing work
um I also do you know there's many
attorneys in the state of New Hampshire
that are experts in education law that
may want to step in and do this role
um as far as creating additional areas
where there might be conflicts that's
actually why we're looking for a
comprehensive approach rather than
saying let's just do the building Aid
law and now let's do the assessment law
and these one-off pieces have we've been
able to kind of fix our one-off pieces
but it's the whole picture now that is
really not coming together so
foreign
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
testifying would you believe that any
publicity from one of my bills is good
publicity so I'm glad I could provide
you the uh example to begin your
testimony thank you both
further questions from committee members
representative Hewitt
um
it seems to me that if you're going to
examine something as as
large as the education law
that it's going to take more than a
lawyer and it's going to take more than
a hundred thousand dollars
uh you know the uniform the UniFi the
commission on uniform state laws has
been in the existence for 30 or 40 years
at least
and uh the the American Bar Association
has come up with a number of standard
laws including uh the Uniform Commercial
Code and things like that uh but that's
a major undertaking and and what we're
talking about here is a a series of laws
enacted at different times under
different circumstances which are viewed
from today's perspective have got real
difficulties and it's not just a matter
of one conflicts with the other one may
conflict with one which may then
conflict with three or four others and
you have to have a process for
eliminating the conflicts before you can
decide what you want to have for a law
and I'm suggesting that uh this
particular statute is probably a little
too easy going in that in those terms uh
to be worthy of well I certainly
wouldn't wouldn't want to stick a
hundred thousand dollars on it and just
hand it to the commissioner of education
and say I have a ball
thank you
and to your point um I I believe all the
things you just said are absolutely true
and we really need to start someplace we
need to start this as a talking point
for the Department to really help us
improve our operations and that's why
we're coming to the committee with this
proposal and you know we would love more
money and more time but we we've got to
get it going because I don't want to be
sitting here in 13 more years from now
and saying which that might happen so
mm-hmm
anything further from the committee
representative Heath thank you
thank you Mom
in Romans 3 it talks about the
commission commissioner or designee will
have exclusive uh supervisory Authority
who would you who do you think should
um should it be the legislature or so I
I think we're gonna
um we actually spoke with the Attorney
General's office this morning and we're
going to ask to say the Department of
Education and consultation with the
Attorney General's office that's the
language they would like and we at the
department are fine with that and we've
talked to representative Hill about
potentially amending it to include that
so all right
um obviously the other thing is too is
the commissioner and the department
can't write bills we have to ask you all
to do that and thankfully representative
Hill wrote this one for us
um but in the proposal would eventually
end up in the hands of the legislature
um hopefully proposing and adjusting
those bills or those laws as needed okay
thank you
anything further from committee members
seeing none
I will close the hearing
on Bill 468 and I will announce that all
these bills will be going through
division two does representative
emmerich want to announce any time that
you'll be hearing them tomorrow
starting at 10. and and then 212.
all right so anybody anybody with any
further interest these will be coming
further question
I I just wanted to remind division three
that uh HP 120 is uh going to be heard
at three o'clock down in children and
family law and it it really helped the
whole process of fast tracking and if
everyone in division three can attend
it looks like the blue sheet on House
Bill 468 is blank
so probably we've heard from everybody
that has an interest
um
I would
all right division one has an
announcement
thanks Mr chairman the retirement
briefing for tomorrow will have to be
rescheduled so it's off for tomorrow
anything for division three you said it
already I just did it thank you okay
um
for there's a reception at five o'clock
in the
Hotel Concord fundraiser where people
are coming to give money
to I believe the speaker and I'd like to
talk to some
um Representatives so
I'd appreciate the attendance of all
that can make it
and kill for a couple hours and then go
over there and
see what they have to offer Concord
hotel
at seven I show it starting at five okay
so I will be there hopefully some others
of you can make it thank you for your
attendance thank you for your
intelligent questions you'll see many
areas that we'll be working on in this
in this committee and there's lots of
ways we can fix them it's going to take
all of our mental abilities to try to
figure out how but there's lots of ways
like some of the things we heard today
that we were discussing
um
talking about building Aid it's in a
separate line
it doesn't need to be in a separate line
we have more money coming into the
um
adequacy then we need
because of the decline in enrollment
depending on how we use that money
We could decide by law to put building
Aid
under
under adequacy that's something that we
could do here we could change the law if
need be to use to put that money in the
place where it needs to be
or we could look at the formula that
puts money into the education trust fund
and say too much of this is going in too
much of that is going in and we could
tweak the percentages that each of those
fun sources of funds except for gambling
money that all goes into
education trust fund but the other
sources are all can be variable keep
that in mind as we go through these
things and try to find out how do we
best spend money on education to have it
work the way we want it to
and of course we welcome the director's
comments on any of these thoughts but
these are some of the things that have
occurred to me as we're discussing all
these bills and where the money comes
from and where it goes so
be
be imaginative there are more ways we
can use this money than has been done in
the past especially as situations change
so I thank you all for your attendance
and we'll see you on Thursday I think we
start at 10 o'clock thank you all for
your attendance and your ideas